Joe rogan experience by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day,
and we're alive.
You,
you're one of those dudes that rocks two phones.
No,
no,
no.
This is an iPod touch.
This phone is broken.
So like I can't listen to music on this phone anymore,
so I just bought an iPod touch.
I'm not that dude,
that dude.
No,
this is just,
it looks like them that like,
like this is my burner.
But no,
it's just,
well,
there's a lot of people that just love fucking around with a bunch of different
pieces of electronics and a few of them.
No,
I prefer one.
It's just when I went to this Verizon to go,
can I have a new phone?
So this was cracked.
They were like,
okay,
that'll be $700.
And I was like,
no,
it won't be.
I will wait until my contract is up.
What's wrong with it?
It's cracked.
The screen is cracked,
which doesn't bother me,
but somehow it,
I,
I'm really bad with,
I'm really hard on everything as my wife will attest.
And uh,
oh yeah.
Not at all.
Not In a ray rice.
Wait,
let's be clear.
But uh,
the Jack is all fucked up so I can't,
I can't hear things in anymore.
You know,
ray rice way will be a statement.
Yeah,
no.
Yeah.
You until somebody else knocks two of their wives out in an elevator like
Michael Vick,
your dog.
Yeah.
That's uh,
yeah,
that was,
that whole scenario is leading to so many different people getting in trouble
for domestic violence and reports of divesting violence.
Man,
Anthony Johnson,
one of the fighters in the UFC,
God suspended just because there was just the,
the possibility that may be something happened.
So there's an inquiry.
I mean we're going through a sea change right now.
Yeah.
And it's all about,
I think because I have talked about this a little bit before,
that it used to be you only knew the shit that you knew that was directly in
front of you,
that you want information you sought out or your friends brought to you.
But now on Facebook and Twitter,
people are like finding of a ray rice who were like,
I didn't know there was a thing called the NFL,
you know what I mean?
Like everybody's getting everybody shit so that the NFL has had domestic
violence for,
you know,
since the dawn of the NFL.
And not that it's any worse than regular society,
but they've had it.
But now it's to the point where people who never were paying attention to the
NFL are noticing it.
Also people are going and looking through the past of a lot of these different
guys.
Yeah.
I think whenever you're dealing with a bunch of like super athletes who are also
involved in an incredibly aggressive sport and you add in head trauma.
Yes.
Repeated head trauma and a lot of them,
like ray rice has said that that's how he was raised or that,
uh,
no,
he wouldn't say it was a Peterson Peterson.
Adrian Peterson said that's how he was raised.
When you repeat getting knocked the fuck out the elevator.
Yeah.
Ray Rice Peterson.
I mean,
I,
I've,
I've pulled the switch off a tree because I had to go get one,
but,
uh,
I didn't have my nuts all cut up.
Like,
I think there's dead nuts.
That was the kid.
It was like that.
There was,
there's a,
from what I read that there was actual like injuries on his genital area.
Really.
That's what I'd like,
you know,
I'm not trying to testify in a court of law,
but I heard that it was like,
I mean there's certainly,
there's abuse and there's,
and there's also discipline and we all that line is changing.
Like I said,
they were going through a sea change where everybody knows everybody shit now.
But,
uh,
I don't,
I don't think you can hide,
but we all had fucked up shit had to happen to us by our parents.
But does mean you have to pass it on to the next know you don't got to pay it
forward.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
And I,
I've been talking about it lately that my parents were raised by immigrants,
immigrants that came over from Italy and Ireland.
And you know those people that came over here in the 1920s they were savages.
They might as well been cave people,
right.
They got on these shitty boats.
It floated across the ocean,
took months.
They got over here,
they got their name change right away and immediately they started fucking and
shit.
Now kids and then they raise those kids with their savage instincts in the
neighborhood that they're not allowed to leave because they have their accent
was too thick and the weird food,
I'll have to leave that neighborhood at the point where Italians weren't
considered to be white.
People aren't white or you know,
it was like Polish people are white and then eventually they lose.
The accents are allowed to integrate into the rest of the of the city.
I had a history professor on yesterday,
Thaddeus Russell who explained that exact same thing.
You know how all these different cultures integrate into society and they're
considered non whites.
Yeah.
For the black folks.
We don't get the integrated.
While it was also his,
his take on it was the unique uh,
aspect of America is that America was the,
the country that had this puritan value system.
Like these people came over and he had this like really re repressive value
system and very repressed society,
but they also had slaves and the slaves didn't,
they didn't accept any of that.
And then they became part of the culture.
Radically influenced the art radically and for influenced the language.
Who the slaves,
the slaves did.
Yeah.
I mean this is one of the most unique things about America is the African
American influence and the western Africans integrating into this really fucked
up puritan,
very repressed society.
And then you see in America,
like 90% of all entertainment comes out of here.
Uh,
a massive amount of innovation comes out of here.
A massive difference in the way we speak English as opposed to the way English
people speak English.
It's so many variables that that came out of that.
And it makes you think like how much of it kind of bringing it all back to the
Peterson thing,
beaten as kids.
How much of the way human beings live our lives is based just on the momentum of
the people that came before us,
whether it's his parents had been him or some fucking weird puritanical society
that you just unluckily we're born into.
Yeah,
well there's,
yeah,
a lot of that is,
but again,
there's that,
I certainly understand that we,
you know,
like I said,
oh,
all this fucked up.
Things happened to us in our childhood.
Some of us go,
I got to put a stop to this.
I go,
you know,
that you make the choice to go,
I got to break the cycle.
And sometimes it's in big ways like,
I'm going to go to college.
Nobody went to college.
And sometimes it's like,
I'm not going to slap my kid in the nuts.
You know what I mean?
Like it just,
I'm going to stick.
I'm going to talk to him.
You know,
and I,
and certainly I was whooped as a kid by different things.
I mean,
I always say my,
one of my grandmother's favorite stories was to talk about how she beat me with
a shoe one time.
And that was thanksgiving.
Everybody sit down and let's hear the beat with the shoe story.
That was not like a in therapy.
She told that story.
He's like,
hey grandma,
tell her how you beat me with a shoe story again.
And everybody would laugh and you know,
and it was a good southern time.
What was the cause?
What did you do that made her beat you in a shoe?
It's funny.
It's the south.
I said,
I said what?
That's it?
Yeah.
So like so uh,
so call me,
say come out.
Come out what you said.
Y'All say what to me so well boss.
Yes ma'am.
Wow.
And I was,
and I lived in the,
I just say the north probably with my mom in the north.
So I didn't know that wasn't a thing in the north that you couldn't say what.
So I didn't know.
And I felt really like tricked,
like I felt in trap,
like nobody give me a list of rules of how it works here in the south and I
won't do those things.
So she,
that's funny man.
That's funny.
I got beat with a shoe for saying what?
Well,
kids,
when they're starting to,
uh,
sort of find themselves when they're starting to establish their own identity,
one of the first things they do is a immediately try to challenge the way you
discipline them and the way you,
you like,
my daughter loves doing that.
I go,
you know,
I'll say to her,
hey,
come on,
we gotta go do something.
That's what she like.
Look at me.
I'm watching TV.
I know you want your TV,
but you got to eat.
Yeah.
It's time to eat.
You know,
I want to watch the show and it's not,
no.
I want to watch show there's no,
no,
we're not negotiating.
Yeah.
This is just what's going to happen.
He's going to get shut off.
Yeah.
No angry.
I would,
I stand by.
It wasn't that testing authority.
I just did.
I just didn't hear.
I'm sorry.
What?
Oh God,
it was entrapment was entrapment.
Yeah,
and button.
Then it,
and then it became every year the story was told is like the,
the,
the bell holiday story.
That's so weird.
Then it fun to beat kids with shoes.
It was fun,
you know?
And I worked out pretty well,
I think.
Yeah.
Great.
But it didn't happen.
It didn't happen every day.
It wasn't a,
it wasn't like the,
here's my time,
we get beat,
but it certainly was the thing that I remember and I'm not going to do that to
my daughter.
You know?
There's no,
there's no shoe beating happening in my house.
Yeah.
It's,
it's sick.
When you,
when you see,
like I saw the pictures of just his kid's leg that were beat with the switch.
It's a sick thing.
Yeah.
It's like beating a kid.
It's not the way to raise a kid.
Yeah.
Like I think there's,
there's that as a pinos apparent.
There's times when you do grab your key,
you might grab,
you can't cause you're like,
don't touch that or don't do that,
or you're going to get hurt and I need to get your attention.
I mean,
my daughter's cool,
but if I yell,
she gets like,
you Yo,
good me.
And then I feel bad.
And I'm like,
man,
that's a different era.
Yeah.
We're raising babies.
It's a softer,
friendlier world.
Well we're getting to it is,
and I just,
uh,
I like that.
I liked that aspect of it.
I liked that we're becoming more aware of the negative impact.
I mean if we didn't learn from the,
the fucked up shit that our parents and grandparents did to us,
then we would really be idiots.
I mean the whole point is that we're evolving.
We have to go,
they did that and I'm going to try to do something one better.
And I think specifically the culture of athletes is that if you're a
professional athlete,
you've probably been coddled since you were in high school and been told and
you've been given a different set of rules to live by.
So that somebody who grew up with ray rice,
he maybe came out of seeing him.
It may not be doing the things he's doing cause they work at fucking Walmart and
they're not allowed to tell people what the fuck they think all the time and
then allowed to do those things.
But Ray rice as a professional athlete as a star is living by a completely
different set of rules.
And what happens to a guy like that and now he's kind of fucked.
I mean,
you know Michael Vick was supposed to be fucked too.
I think if there America likes a comeback,
do you don't suppose nobody was more fucked than Mike Tyson was when he,
when he was convicted for raping,
went to jail and he's sent,
seemed to come out of that.
Okay,
America likes to come back.
That is true.
If he does the things that allow him to,
you know what I mean?
Like if he,
like I always think about tiger woods.
America hasn't accepted him back because they were unfortunately can't go to
jail for cheating on your wife.
Like if he could have gone to jail and then like people are like,
oh,
he was in jail for 18 months right now we'll let them come back.
But we're still,
people are still judging him for what he did.
Could you imagine how happy women would be if a guy could go to jail for
cheating on his wife?
And it was so excited.
They would be blogs written every day.
What were women would be recounting stories from highschool asking their
boyfriends to be put back in jail.
Yeah.
The thing is,
it happened a decade ago.
Yes,
they would be,
their professional victim crusade would be out in full force.
They had no,
there's,
and so,
but you can't,
since you can't do that,
tiger woods is still walking around with his head down,
like going,
oh,
no,
sorry,
I was on an airplane.
It was really funny.
And,
uh,
there was this guy and his wife and they were in front of us and,
um,
the,
uh,
the guy was going over the golf score and the woman had like a golf a visor on.
So I guess they probably both played golf.
And the guy was going over there and he goes like this.
He goes,
ah.
uh,
tiger,
blew it in the whatever round.
I don't follow golf.
I don't know how it works.
And she goes,
of course he did.
What have you done lately?
Really shitting on tiger woods.
Golfers the fuck saying has ever known you can't,
tiger unfortunately did not go to jail for it.
So he can never really recover from it unless he,
you know,
his wife,
if his wife had stayed with him then they would have been like,
okay,
they worked it out because his wife left him as I understand,
you know,
you get to like 1415 women,
you go,
I think this isn't working out and then,
but he can't,
there's no like there's no thing to do.
There was no,
it's not like even with Coby where like the court case ended,
whether you believe it ended to the right way,
it was at least resolved.
So there's was like,
no,
I can just play in Nike.
He's like,
okay,
well fuck with you now.
You know you can come back in the fold.
But,
and especially cause tiger is not as good as he was before that,
which is really shocking.
I think that's,
I feel like it's mental.
I think it's totally like,
that's what I'm saying.
He didn't.
I think he knows and I mean,
I don't know tiger woods at all,
but I just feel like the thing,
I've been that guy where you're like,
I fucked up and there's no way to get out.
I just got to sit in my juices for a while and hope it passes.
Well also,
I don't think either one of us could ever understand what it's like to be a that
famous and be that hated.
Yes.
And it started when you were 19 you know,
that's the thing to me about the same as professional athletes.
You became famous before your brain was for,
your fucking still has a soft spot,
you know?
Yeah.
We were all,
you were not a full grown.
You've already been full girl.
Yeah.
You didn't even have your man wait on you.
Shoulders yet,
you know,
and suddenly one of those famous people on the planet.
I understand why on his side,
like,
you know,
as a kid who was a nerd and went to Stanford and his calm and his dad has been
to play golf forever,
that he was like,
I think it was like to have sex with lots of women.
I just never had that chance.
And I know I got married and that was probably a dumb idea,
but I get that.
But then you can't,
uh,
you know,
you,
he got caught.
Well,
there's also,
I think this is just speculation,
but I think there's all of this is [inaudible] with me as well.
There's,
there's a thing that goes along with being a great athlete.
There's like this conquer mentality.
Like they can't be beaten.
I mean,
Muhammad Ali screaming,
I'm a greatest of all time.
When he did that,
everybody loved it.
They love it.
Half the people loved it and half the people thought we need to.
Yeah.
We need to draft him into the military and force him to be our bitch.
Yeah,
true.
And I don't mean try not to say that word,
but yes,
that's,
yeah.
You try not to say,
bitch,
I tried it.
I,
I'm,
I'm that guy.
Don't let them get you bro.
No,
it's not a bunch of female dog.
I know.
Yeah.
But we,
but it's also,
you know,
a slur for women.
So yeah,
but not always.
It's a lot of times square for men.
Well that it's become that just like nigger is not always a slur for black
people.
It's also dude over there.
But you're allowed to call him.
If I say Jamie,
you nigger,
that's like a terrible thing.
I even,
I got wait,
slow down.
I got nervous even here to come out of my own mouth.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like,
like settle down bitch.
Like that's fine.
I'm not telling you,
I'm not trying to,
you personally.
That's my,
yeah,
I'm just,
this is how I,
you know,
they got you got up,
but they may be already had me.
You're not going to go my past and be like,
man,
he used to have,
he was the bitch guy.
Look at the amount of pitches he used.
Yeah.
Good.
It's really scaled back.
No one from three to zero.
I say other words,
I say nigger a lot.
It just,
I feel like I can,
but I don't say that in a way where like I would never,
I would only jokingly say to my black friend,
what's up my Nigga?
I wouldn't say that.
I don't call him that.
And I talk about,
I use the word nigger on stage a lot cause I'm talking about it,
but I'm right.
So I'm not,
it's not the word police,
it's just we all just have our own set of rules that we established.
So thrown off by your refusal of the word bitch that I forgot what it is,
what my entire point was going to be.
That's my,
that's my goal.
Yeah.
I've got this,
it's like a,
you know,
when the cage,
I gotta make sure you use your nervous gasket.
That's a good move.
Uh,
we were talking about,
uh,
oh Muhammad Ali,
I'm the greatest of all time.
And I was just saying that like,
some people loved it,
some people hate it.
It wasn't no doubt.
And the DIS,
the people love that conqueror mindset.
They love the person who's extremely confident.
Yes,
they love love like Mike Tyson when he was in his prime.
Yeah.
You know that,
that,
you know,
there's something about a guy who's at his best who thinks he can do whatever
the fuck he wants and then keeps pulling it off.
The people that love to see him fail,
but they also love to see them succeed.
But then some people love to hate that guy,
you know?
So if that's there,
they,
you know,
it's true of all these guys.
I mean,
you know.
Yeah.
Jon Jones thing,
you know?
Yeah.
The people also get God,
why is he so good?
Oh,
hate the hate that.
Hate that.
I don't like that.
He's so good.
Yeah.
There's no doubt there's a,
there's an issue with that,
but I speculate on what it's like to be that guy when you are that good at
something like golf,
like a guy like tiger woods who was arguably the greatest golfer of all time or
right up there with them.
I mean for the,
the time when he was on a roll,
I'm not a golf historian,
but as he had like a,
like a 10 year run where it was just like that we had was almost,
I think it was unparalleled where he just,
where he,
he was going to be competitive every weekend and he played golf and he was going
to,
he wasn't ever going to,
he was always going to make the cut.
And golfers I know enough that they,
there's wild swings.
Like a guy who wins one week may not make the cut the next week.
It's mostly mental.
I mean it's left physical,
but it's also you have to hold yourself together and recover.
And so there's wild swings in golf and he had an amazing consistency that even
if he didn't,
when he was in the top 10 and then all of a sudden that went away because it's
mental,
I think,
well,
like all sports is,
everything is mental.
But I think in that with golf especially,
like if you're,
if you're,
if you're not mentally in the thing,
you can't do the thing.
It's not about your physical gifts.
He's still strong.
He's still bigger than everybody does have physical issues too.
Now though doesn't he does a lot of problems and knee problems and stuff.
Yeah,
he does.
He does,
but a lot of that stuff and you know,
but he's still not too old too.
I mean,
you know tigers at the age that most golfers are sometimes in their prime,
like in that like sort of late thirties this is when he should be good.
Not Back.
But you know he's also,
he put,
he though he was the first Gulf to put muscle on and really work out.
Sometimes you know,
if you put too much muscle on you can fuck yourself up eventually.
Yeah.
Well then also fucks up your,
your coordination.
Sometimes like with pool players,
I play a lot of pool and pool players.
One of the things that happens to them is they lift a lot of weights.
If they start lifting weights,
they start getting like really tense pool players,
lift weights.
That's a thing
we'll place and trying to be more fit because of being more fit gives you more
energy.
Yay.
Longer matches.
I understand that.
And you can maintain your concentration.
I know it seems counterintuitive.
I get that you would like want to be in good shape but being buffed to play
pool,
he was like,
that would be,
that's kind of tough but
strong your core and you're like a lot of times pool players develop back issues
because you're bending over all the time.
So,
uh,
just the idea that you're lifting weights to keep your body strong,
but in doing so,
sometimes you'd create all this tension and then that tension fucks up your feel
for where the ball's going.
And I would imagine the guy like tiger started getting pretty buff.
You know,
there's a lot of that in like how you knock a ball around on a golf course as
well.
Right.
It's just that delicate touch.
Yeah.
That it's fair that it's a lot of uh,
fast twitching and let attention and releasing and yeah,
there was a guy named Willie hoppies,
like a famous billiards player from the early 19 hundreds,
like one of the all time greats.
And he wouldn't even drive a car,
wouldn't even do anything with his hands until he got to that table.
Just didn't,
didn't touch anything,
just like would eat his food and just no tension at all.
He wanted his arms to be delicate and loose,
so he had a full control where the ball was going at all times.
I wish I could do that with the comedy.
I can't,
I can't talk and just got to sit here and be in a,
yeah.
Yeah.
Some people like that,
man.
Some people rest their voice and shit and they drink
like before the show.
I do like to do a thing where it's like,
just don't talk to me for an hour.
If it's a big show,
I do like the shit.
I like to shut it down.
I do the opposite.
Really?
Yeah.
When it's a big shot,
I like to talk a lot and have fun.
Oh yeah.
So that when I go out there,
I'm loose.
I'm having a good time.
I guess it depends.
Last night I did Largo and I d I had the other comics backstage and we were
talking,
but I think it was because I want to do that because there was a lot of industry
people out there and I just didn't want it to focus too much on the fact that
like,
oh,
this is just my career,
you know?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
People paying attention to you and staring at you.
What do we,
what can we do with money to go in his general direction?
Can we sign him up for this?
It's Hildy.
Yes,
cause he the,
is he the friend of the guy,
neighbor,
the wacky neighbor that cosmo Kramer is his way into the room and see the
feature.
Got It.
Comes in for six episodes and everybody loves it.
Doesn't want to see him too much.
Yeah.
It could be that.
We can't overstate as welcome.
You had an awesome show man.
You had a really good show,
a groundbreaking show that for some reason some fucking suits decided they
should take it from the very profitable FX and Fx,
sex,
which nobody even was informed was a real channel.
It was a,
it was a,
I,
you know,
I'm better for the show having happened.
I certainly feel like a little bit,
the show getting canceled and sent way made it a better story for people.
Like you have now become like Woodstock,
like more people claiming they were there then were there,
I watched it occasionally,
like we were like,
I was there every night and I couldn't.
But it's like,
but now people,
when it was gone,
people got more,
it got more attention for it being gone and,
and so I really appreciate that.
But yeah,
it was a crazy,
well you,
you know,
you,
you were known for being a standup comic and then all of a sudden you hear,
oh,
FX is doing a show with Kamau bell and it's being produced by Chris Rock.
Yeah.
So whenever you say Chris Rock,
we all get excited when the greatest comedians of all time it's producing this
show.
There's fucking show gotta be fantastic.
Absolutely.
And you,
what you did it,
I thought that was really unique is you tackled some pretty interesting subjects
and some things that you never see discuss like rape jokes.
I mean you had that thing with Lindy West,
is that her name?
[inaudible] and Jim Norton's that his name?
Yeah.
I used to want to fuck her name.
I appreciate you,
you guys got into some complex subject matter for television,
which is late night television,
which is just,
I mean usually it's like my new song is all about love and I never,
I never wanted a late night talk show.
It just ended up being,
that was the format that they called it.
Like I just wanted to show and they said it comes on after 11 I'm like,
okay,
come on at eight.
But there's the thing if there's a person who's standing on a stage talking to
an audience about the world and it's a late night talk show and I was always
sort of rebelling against that format and trying to make it just a show that I
would want to watch.
Well I think you did a good job at doing that.
When when a show is on a network there's always going to be like a bunch of
people that are also trying to change the direction of it.
Like you got your ideas and then you got your producers ideas,
which ad hopefully to your ideas and the director's ideas which added and then
you've got an executive and hey man,
you had a lot of fucking kick cooks in the kitchen.
Yes you absolutely do.
And that co coming from the world of stand up and also the world zoom.
I like the solo show that got me the thing.
I add friends helping me and I had people help me.
But it was ultimately,
it was,
my words were the thing that we're coming out of my mouth and my idea,
nobody people could say,
what should,
you should do this.
And I'd be like,
oh,
I'll think about it.
But when you're in that,
that meat grinder environment,
especially when it became daily,
there's so many people who are sort of yelling things at you and at some point
you just,
for lack of,
you can't.
If you can't top their idea,
you sort of go,
I guess we'll do that.
You know?
Or,
or if somebody goes like,
I just told her,
I said this yesterday,
like somebody will be like,
oh,
you know what I was thinking we could do a cold open.
Well I don't really want to do a cold open cause that's just not the kind of
show I want.
Well I think we have,
we have a big guest on,
we'll do the cold open.
Well I don't really want to do that.
Well I asked the guests he wants to do it.
Okay.
I guess we'll do it.
And then the guest shows up and go,
we're doing this call though.
He's like,
I don't want to do it.
And you go,
oh,
but we already bought the whip cream and then suddenly have this vision of like,
why are we doing this?
Why we bought it?
Just there's this machine of television and this machine that suddenly are just
as you either.
I felt like I was,
it was like a meat grinder and either I was putting the meat in the grinder or I
was the meat for the grinder.
And in that format,
when it was daily,
a lot of days I was the meat.
I think it gets to a point where you're like a John Stewart type dude where
you're,
you get to decide what goes in the grinder.
Yeah.
And I think that Stuart,
I've read lots of stuff on him.
He,
it took him two and a half years to get the daily show.
Like we don't all,
we think of the daily show,
we're really thinking about 10 the last 10 years of the daily show me,
we're not thinking about that first.
When he first got there and took over from Craig Kilborn and it was sort of a
wacky,
uh,
afternoon parody show of like news event show,
you know,
so it was more of like a pop culture type thing.
It was,
again,
it was like a parody of those.
They don't really do these anymore,
but those afternoons shows that you see like you know,
evening magazine,
those things
where it's like we went to the floor show and found this new floors to Bubba and
John took it a more political direction,
but he had the,
from everything I've read comedy central didn't want it,
but he was in a position where he wasn't being told he was the face of the
network and that all the pressure was on him because they were,
he had south park and he had all the,
all the other stuff on comedy central wears on effects on Fx FX.
It was,
they had one night of original programming that wasn't,
that included me when it was like the league or it's always sunny or Jim
Jefferies every other night.
It would be like you'd be somebody be at home watching a mad about you rerun and
enjoying it and then suddenly a blackout would come on screaming about the
events of the day and I get,
they'd be like,
Whoa,
no,
no.
I was enjoying Paul Riser from the 90s of black guy,
a black guy.
He just said that like in a way this that.
Is that something you are acutely aware of?
Like how they were programming it like,
because I'm aware of the audience.
If you're watching a mad about you rerun,
and I'm not in any way insulting mad about you,
but I'm saying if you're like,
oh and salt,
that's fine.
Just don't shit's bad for America.
Good for Paul Rogers Bay.
I just don't have any opinion.
It's at,
that's your thing.
If you're watching a rerun of some sitcoms from the 90s and you're enjoying it,
which you can,
and then suddenly I come on screen and I'm the op on basically the opposite of
that.
I'm a guy who's talking about right now and not talking about what happened in
the 90s and I'm a black guy and you're just watching a bunch of white people on
the upper west side of Manhattan and talk about,
well,
we go,
how are we going to get to the coffee shop if we don't bump it up?
And then I come on,
they're talking about homophobia.
You know,
like I get this is,
it's a hard transition.
Whereas if there's a network that's programmed where I'm a part of the package,
then it segues and things.
We'll segue one into the other one.
Yeah.
Not only it guy that's,
you know,
polar opposite of the nineties during the current guy,
but a progressive black cock intelligent who's knocking about some controversial
and it's hard to like,
it becomes hard to box.
It's not like I'm doing,
oh,
this is what I expect black guys to do it.
And I'm doing things where,
you know,
where I'm being vulnerable are also talking about issues that I don't know
anything about and I'm trying to learn about them.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's huge.
And that's a,
I thought it was an interesting approach,
uh,
of your show that you don't really see too much when it comes to controversial
issues.
Like a guy who had set her pretending to be the expert in everything and you
know,
the voice of reason,
you kind of like laid back and ask questions and try to piece it together on the
spot.
That's what that was like.
The man on the street stuff we did was always this stuff people responded to the
best of in addition to the,
at the debates we did,
uh,
put like when I would go and treat and talk to people and we would make comedy
out of what we were talking about,
whether we agreed or not,
just out of like me talking to them about whatever the issues were and that
stuff,
I always felt like my comedy that we would have doesn't work if I pretend to be
the smartest guy in the room.
Like people say I'm smart,
which sometimes when people say that they feel like you're smart and they sort
of shake your head like I didn't expect that.
Or also like industry,
like we don't know what to do with that.
Yeah,
but I,
so I will take that and I certainly like to read no stuff like you do,
but I'm not the smartest of my friends.
I'm the funny one of my friends,
you know what I mean?
I'm the one who they're like,
oh,
come out.
You don't know what you're talking about.
You know,
here,
read this.
And so that's the place that it works best for me not to go on,
stay on TV and be like,
let me explain.
Unless I'm talking about something about being black in America,
then I feel like I've got some research I've done.
I've done quite a bit of comic or gay and that you're an expert in.
Yeah.
There's areas where I feel like I will hold my opinion,
but you know,
for a lot of stuff,
I'm just as I'm trying to see,
we don't have to know everything all the time.
When I've watched your show,
the first thing I thought besides that,
this is a really good show and really unique,
is that you should be on the Internet.
I'm like,
why does it need just do this fucking show on the Internet when he beat himself?
100% yeah,
because you can get the numbers on the Internet that are just as big as any
number.
You got an FX xxx.
Exactly the numbers we got.
I think it was called historically low.
I think I can do that on,
on the Internet.
But it seems like there's a,
you,
you developed a following.
There's a lot of um,
really a lot of positive reactions to what you were doing and it seems like you
can carry that onto the internet smoothly and it would just take off like
wildfire.
Right now I was,
there was a lot of things that happened when the show got canceled.
Like we were cause so me and my wife,
my daughter moved to New York for the shoot.
We'd never lived in New York,
never thought of it like New York.
My wife was born and raised in Monterey,
California.
It doesn't want to be out of northern California.
So we moved in,
I lived there.
So we moved to this.
So going to show that canceled.
And then there was this period of like,
I don't know who do you call it?
Crippling depression.
Like we're just like,
what happens next?
What do I do it right?
Do we stay here?
Do we leave?
And then my wife got pregnant,
she's pregnant with her second kid graduations.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And so it was this thing about like,
well,
okay,
now what do we do?
Are we going to raise a kid?
Like,
are we gonna have a baby in New York?
And they just sounded like a reality show.
I didn't want to watch like,
you know,
these couple have a baby.
No,
we can't,
not in Manhattan.
And so we just moved back to the bay like six weeks ago and everything in my
life has been like,
okay.
Like I just feel like I can breathe again and more about San Francisco than New
York.
Uh,
I think New York is New York is the greatest city in the world.
I'm not trying to,
I think it is,
but it's also a hard city to live in if I feel like if you're from there born
and raised,
you can do it.
Or if you move there and have the means to have the means to live the life you
want or you're 22 you know like I feel like those,
but I'm not any of those things at this point.
If the bay,
you get all the good stuff that New York has,
all the culture,
all the ideas,
all the diversity,
but there's just a more is more wide open space and there's more,
there's more conversation.
There's more like,
you know,
it just,
it feels like you can,
it's an area where people move there to be curious.
You know what I mean?
Like they moved there and be like,
oh,
I'm going to see if I can turn my.com idea until,
you know,
or people go to,
I'm going to go there to be gay as I want to be.
Find out if I can be too gay.
You know what I mean?
To Go,
this is a $4 million house.
Well,
yeah,
we live in Berkeley,
so yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We,
we,
I lived,
I lived in San Francisco and moved back and my joke is that San Francisco was
like,
now you live in Berkeley.
It was like,
I can't,
you know,
we can't,
I can't live in San Francisco anymore.
Nobody can know it's the city is only seven by seven people don't realize that
it's tiny.
Yeah.
And at some point I think Gavin Newsome,
the mayor realized,
wait,
this could all be high end real estate.
The entire city could behind real estate.
That's kind of what it is now.
Yeah.
So it's become a thing where unless you've lived there for 40 years and own your
property,
you are,
people are being kicked out of like old people are being kicked out of
apartments.
They've lived in for their entire lives because landlords are turning their
buildings into condos and it's really a big deal there.
I lived in San Francisco during the Vietnam War.
I lived in San Francisco when I was a little kid.
When you said that was totally like you were in the Vietnam War.
And I'm like,
that's so funny way that I lived there in [inaudible] 72 I lived there during
the Vietnam War.
I was an objector conscious as objective as a four year old.
I was seven.
Yeah.
I knew better,
but uh,
it shaped the way I look at the world very,
very,
uh,
very much so.
It's a very,
it's too open sometimes I think people like it.
San Francisco gets so liberally,
gets conservative,
like were there like where they get very tunnel vision in their liberalness.
So that's,
but I think for me that's,
I've learned to understand that and I looked and that's a part of why I think my
act of uptodate is,
I've learned to fuck with that.
Yeah.
So I don't,
it's not perfect,
but it just,
it just feels like you can breathe out there and you still get all this stuff.
Like you don't,
you're not missing any of the concerts or any of the movies or any of the food
of New York,
but you get to like,
you get to a,
everything's not 400 feet tall.
That is an interesting thing though,
isn't it?
How like you can get so liberal that it almost becomes conservative cause become
so dogmatic and your idea because liberals get very focused on their version of
liberalism and so aggressive about it.
Yes.
Yeah.
You know,
that's,
that's a big thing about it is it's not about kindness and love and
understanding so much.
It's about pushing their idea with kindness,
love and understanding should be,
and you disagree.
You're a fucking mail pig.
Patriarchal privilege.
He's a shit die in a fire.
He gets,
it gets pretty aggressive.
I agree with the white privilege part,
but uh,
no,
I think that's,
people don't realize and that's what the show was trying to do,
that people get caught up in.
Like I'm a,
for example,
my friends,
I've Milton black friends who are like,
Milton black has the thing and they sort of ignore like the,
like the gay rights side of it and suddenly somebody starts talking about gay
rights.
Like no,
that's not important.
It's militancy,
black militancy.
And then there's gay people were like,
no,
no.
Immigration is not important.
It's about getting,
so people get caught in their lane and his show and my life is about,
and how we,
all of us on the right side of the issues need to get in the same hot tub
together and figure it out.
You know,
like we need to sort of talk that we're all on the right side of me up until hot
tub.
That could be a problem.
You don't get to talk to what gay dudes,
what militants or in that you can't have a fucking bra and a hot tub who has a
brawl in a hot thing.
It can happen in a hot tub.
I never saw a fucking guy knocked the girl out in the elevator before the ray
rice video,
but apparently it's positive.
I'm sure there's lots of footage you guys get to know people getting knocked out
in elevators.
But I think brought somebody Google hot to abroad and see what comes up.
This is a very famous story about a guy,
I don't know if you heard this one a few years ago.
He was a newscaster and um,
he was a gay guy that was in the closet.
He's in like Oklahoma TV or some shit like that and uh,
you know,
one of those.
Thanks Bob.
All right,
today's top story.
You know,
one of those fucking weird guys.
He woke up with a dead guy next to him.
They had been doing crystal meth all night and,
and having gay sex and uh,
the guy had a belt around his neck and the guy is fixated while doing auto
erotic fixation and he passed out.
They passed out together in this hot tub.
So he woke up in the hot tub,
mapped out doing pills with a blue guy next to him with a belt around his neck.
But again,
not a fight and not slide,
allegedly were all,
they were all in it together.
Skiing,
hot tub brawl leads to arrest,
but that's Michigan man.
Those are crazy white people.
That's a different kind of human being.
I love that you googled out to have Raul and found something that
I said that because I wanted to see and I knew that I knew it was coming.
Of course it is,
but it's probably us.
That style of fighting styles.
It will be the next UFC hot tub.
Rollen yeah,
people use techniques you've got to push off the back of the time.
It's very important to get the Ph balance of the water.
It makes a big difference.
Don't get it in your mouth.
It'll affect your breathing.
There's a lot going on with hot tub brawling and hot to bro,
but it's funny,
one of my favorite,
just to remind me,
this is like one of my favorite things about San Francisco and just favorite
things I ever saw and so it was just cool.
It was like,
that's so gay community crystal method has been a problem in the gay community.
It's an awesome thing.
Yet depends on dependents worked off.
When you take somebody out there,
is that really the Keith Richards version of it?
Like Crystal Meth is working for me.
You know,
somebody up there.
It can't be bad for everybody.
The otherwise I to stop selling it.
Is that really how it works?
Is that why Mcdonald's is open and some people are eating it and feeling it.
I had a fucking egg muffin this morning.
It was delicious.
Don't have one tonight.
No Egg.
Mcmuffins unlike crystal meth do not require you to continue using them all day
to maintain a state of normalcy.
Maybe.
I think we would like you to use them everyday.
They would,
but they stopped selling them after 10:30 AM that's just cause they understand
coming junkies.
They understand.
That's right.
You can't get the,
you can't get the egg mcmuffin or up to 10 30,
because we don't want to cause a problem in America.
There was a billboard in San Francisco,
like on the bus shelter,
like in the gay neighborhood where I had to,
I used to take the bus from there,
uh,
cause I'd hang up and uh,
there was a billboard and it was a guy like all it was was,
it was,
uh,
it was a billboard said don't do crystal meth or something and the image of the
billboard was a guy,
I'll just do it like,
like,
so you're,
it's like you're standing over his shoulder and he's doing this
and it was implied that he's getting fucked in the ass and didn't know it
because he was on crystal meth.
Why he was the great,
you're just like,
ah,
like he's got this horrified look on his face cause it's from the priest and
he's got his shirt off and it's from the perspective of like awesome guys
fucking him in the ass.
So he's waking off yet in the middle of like the crystal meth Hayes.
He was making poor choices and it was like a thing at the bus shelter right next
to the Safeway,
which is like,
I love this city.
I was like ridiculous ad though.
I mean if he can greenlit,
they got my attention.
I haven't done crystal since or before.
Thanks man.
Learn wacky ads like that sounds like a bad scene.
I think San Francisco is like,
if not the smartest one of the smartest towns in the world.
I mean I think it gets a lot of credit for that,
but I,
and I think that it,
it can be,
but I also think that if you like the comedy crowds get attention for being
smart.
I think that can be true,
but it's also,
you can also walk into San Francisco Club and be like,
where did these people come from?
You know what I mean?
Like there's tourists,
but there's also just a lot of like,
you know,
I don't want to try and bridge and tunnel.
There's a lot of like people coming into San Francisco and there's awesome
crowd.
The original San Francisco people who live there are just people like,
you will cry,
you will go to neighborhoods in San Francisco or like,
you're like,
these people don't know it's the gas city on earth.
Do the plumber.
He doesn't know that this is like the most progressive city in the plant on the
planet.
Do you think that this,
this whole w w what,
what'd you call it?
Gentrification.
Is that what they call it and I would call it then people buy up the real estate
and it's going through the roof where they create neighborhoods where
neighborhoods weren't before or should have been and they didn't want to make a
neighborhood.
Is that,
what can you do?
What can they do to stop that?
I mean almost nothing.
The amount of money,
the wealth that's in the concentrated wealth makes it,
I mean,
unless we want to storm the streets and get all like Ukraine in there,
the concentrated wealth makes it damn near impossible because the first,
not the first way,
but when I moved to San Francisco in the 90s,
there was the.com,
the first.com bubble.
And they tried to gentrify the mission.
And back then what they were doing was trying to,
it was tearing down stuff and building new things and neighborhood flexed on
them and said in the mission that historically Latino neighborhood and the
neighborhood flex and said,
no,
you can't do this.
And I don't know how he did it,
but they stopped them.
But now the money is so much bigger and the bubble didn't burst and it's Google
money and Facebook money,
which is going to last for the end of time,
uh,
time being 10 years from now.
Uh,
but that the money so concentrated that,
and they're now being sneaky about how they gentrified.
They don't tear the buildings down.
They make the buildings look like they're the same buildings.
They just redo the inside.
Yeah.
So it becomes invisible.
So you just go,
did you suddenly you don't know that they're being re gentrified,
but then you'd go,
man,
that's there.
Sure are a lot more wine bars around here than they used to be.
But they don't look like that from the outside.
They look and you go into them and they're just unbelievably renovated.
Yes.
Well what the fuck did you guys do?
They've kept the outsides and situate that.
You don't that it's,
it's more invisible.
But yeah,
the Google,
like there's the Google bus in San Francisco,
like all the Google lights used to live in like mountain view down by Palo Alto.
But then Google does this thing that's become very controversial.
They have a free bus that will take you from certain San Francisco neighborhoods
straight to Google so that you,
so that the 25 year old people who work at Google can live in the cool hip city,
but then get to work for free.
But what that does is that every stop on the Google bus line,
it changes the neighborhood cause people want to live next to the Google bus
line.
And so then suddenly neighborhoods that like it would have been a poor
neighborhood or a struggling neighborhood.
People are buying the property there and renovating things and then pushing the
other people out of the neighborhood.
So in a sense the Google bus,
which is good because it keeps cars off the highway,
right?
And it also helps Google out because people get on the bus and start working
right away.
So when people go,
it's great,
we have free Wifi.
No,
that's how you can work.
So it takes cars off the road.
It's extensively helps people.
It keeps you from living in places they don't want to live,
but it changes the neighborhood and kicks people out of the neighborhood.
It's a very super controversial thing that San Francisco is dealing with right
now.
San Francisco's and wealth for people who don't know is in this weird,
stupid category that doesn't even make any sense.
I have some friends that live in Atherton and a,
they rent a house there,
but the house is worth $15 million
and it's not worth 15 nine I know.
You don't just not,
you don't walk in and go,
this is a $15 million house,
dude.
You don't even walk in and go,
this is a $1 million house.
It's just a house.
It's a fucking normal.
I mean,
yes,
it's worth,
if I had a guest,
like if you put it in a decent neighborhood in,
you know,
studio city.
Yeah,
it's a $2 million house.
It's a very nice house,
but it's 15 fucking million dollars.
Yes.
It doesn't make any sense.
And I'm walking around,
I'm like,
how is this house worth $15 million?
It doesn't make any sense to me.
It's a sauna.
It's got a normal backyard.
It doesn't have a view of the fucking,
the continental divide and they'll have a wiffle ball stadium.
Crazy.
It's crazy.
The money there is so over the top,
the concentrated wealth artificially inflates the values of everything around
it,
which means people who've lived there forever suddenly being told,
you can't live here anymore.
They can't afford it.
It would have to look $15 million.
It's like,
what is the fucking mortgage on?
Something like that.
Yeah.
You can't.
It's like that was a month or so.
Which way do you have to have to keep a $50 million house?
The mortgage would be like probably close to $100,000 a month.
So that's a million,
$200,000 a fucking,
yeah.
Yes,
yes.
That's insane.
You and you haven't,
what if the sink Britain,
you know,
there's all the,
yeah.
You know,
you can't,
you know the earth moves,
the earth moves.
Yeah.
That's a big one.
All the insurance because you're in,
you're all at your house is built on a fault line,
you know?
So,
yeah,
that is completely,
it's,
it sucks,
but there's no,
you,
it's capitalism.
You know,
capitalism.
Unchecked is not necessarily the best thing,
you know?
And what's the option now if you say capitalism unchecked,
it's capitalism sort of.
We'll always capitalism.
I feel like unless you sorta go,
hey,
maybe we should,
you know this should,
we should keep an area for people who've lived here.
We shouldn't allow people to get kicked out of their houses for old people
should never be kicked out of their house and they're paying the rent that they
were agreed to pay when they moved in in 80 a hundred years ago.
That's the things that have to be,
people should be allowed to buy whatever property they want to buy this for
sale.
But it's also a thing where you shouldn't make it easier on those people and
harder on the people who actually don't have the ability to go live somewhere
else.
Yeah.
It gets really tricky when they run out of places they can go to two because
when you're,
especially if you have a rent control type situation.
Yeah.
Once,
if they boot you out of that,
good fucking luck,
find a place for 800 bucks a month.
No.
And,
and,
and as fear,
if you're an old person,
you know,
you're,
you don't know,
your family may not live in the area and you have to go,
you're suddenly,
you're moving all your shit like your dad.
Like,
you know,
like what,
who wants to do that in my mom was in Bloomington,
Indiana.
She pays $600 a month I think for a two bedroom townhouse.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's,
it's not nice but it's for $600 a months.
It's a nice,
you know,
like it's a,
and,
and I think about that and there's no way anywhere in the bay area that she
could ever,
like we talked about her moving out there and I'm like,
I don't,
I'm not making that FX money anymore.
We have to figure out,
yeah,
we got to get something else going before we can move you out of here.
Cause you're not gonna find anything for $600 a month.
Berkeley's nice though.
I like Berkeley.
Berkeley is milk calm.
It's like a,
it's an interesting sort of environment.
It's a super leftie,
very hippy environment.
But it's also not,
it's also very sort of young and a little bit gutter punk too.
It's like you,
it's funny like if you go down by the downtown Berkeley Bart Station,
it is very gutter punk and like sort of kid spare changing and you know it's a
very sort of,
it's,
it's a place that those people hang out and I was down there with my daughter
pushing the stroller and I felt like the Weirdo,
like pushing the baby store,
like we're not gonna get a baby frog.
Oh that's weird.
He's selling it like I felt like I'm the Weirdo.
You guys are all in the streets.
Well does that San Francisco and the bay area itself is so accepting of like
homeless people.
We all would foot,
I forgot how many like living in New York for two years in New York,
people think New York has a homeless problem.
It's like,
no,
you guys have about 12 dudes.
I've met them all while I was there.
They're all very nice.
But like San Francisco,
it's a,
it's thick with it or the bay area because it's temperate and we have social
services for those people and that is,
that is a good thing.
And I lived in a neighborhood where I knew all the homeless people and they were
all pretty cool.
There was was really a time when I had a problem with it,
you know,
and they just do their thing and,
and you know,
it's also great,
the hidden benefit of homeless people when you walk out of here in San
Francisco,
there's a culture of if you walk out of a restaurant and you have leftovers and
you don't want to eat them,
you just put him on a trashcan and you blink and they're gone.
Right.
When you feel like you did something,
yeah,
I'm a good person.
Whereas it's not that culture.
I'm glad to be back in that culture.
You feel like I've done a good thing.
I'm a charitable individual cause I didn't finish my spaghetti.
That's funny.
Do you think that,
well,
I think the real issue is a lot of these people are like,
they have mental issues and the mental health care in this country just doesn't,
doesn't,
it's not up to snuff.
I mean,
these people are just not being taken care of the way a culture should probably
look after its citizens.
Well,
yeah,
and I think I've,
I don't know this for sure,
but from what I heard in the barriers when Reagan was governor,
he turned out,
he opened up the doors in the hospital.
It wasn't just when he was governor,
when he was president,
he became president.
He changed the,
the,
what the requirements are and you know,
said,
Oh,
you guys can feed yourself.
You can put a fork to your mouth.
But yeah.
Oh yeah,
you're free.
You're free.
Mental health issues are,
are serious and,
and it's,
and forget
homes.
You will,
America's probably number one issue with mental health issues.
I mean,
you know if the win when we go to the,
take it back to the football player thing,
the NFL rookie symposium suit involves sitting down with a therapist and talking
about,
ah,
okay,
you're about to make a lot of money and you had everything in life,
but let's try to figure out what,
what in your past is going to lead you to make bad decisions in the future?
That's all well and good,
but the reality is you're never going to be able to change anybody out and have
a fucking conversation.
The reality being a guy who's poor to being a guy who's a fucking NFL superstar,
making millions of dollars.
Boy,
what a transition.
I don't mean one conversation.
Yeah,
I mean like,
yeah,
I feel like,
I mean,
I actually feel like every black person in America that would,
I'll take those reparations free therapy,
just give every black person in America a free therapy session once a week for
the rest of their life.
It will change the,
it'll change American white people need therapy to speak for you people.
I'm just thinking,
how dare you.
You people,
you people,
that's how it works.
Yeah.
I'm married to one of your people so I can say that.
Good for you.
Yeah.
Thank God someone's doing it.
I think also the,
the real problem with NFL players,
the unaddressed problem with mental health,
it's also the fucking concussions.
You know,
the one thing about concussions is it creates depression and it makes guys way
more susceptible to being impulsive violence,
more PSAs.
And you're also,
you're so used to a violent world,
a world of constant collisions and explosions and pushing people off you and
screaming at people on the line.
And in that world it's Def,
it's difficult to transition between that world and the calm world of domestic
living.
And I think that's true.
I just sit when sometimes when people say that they make it sound like that's an
excuse for what?
For domestic abuse.
That like,
well he's,
these are violent men and violet would a violent game.
And I feel like,
yeah,
that's true.
But they still have to be human beings outside of that.
They still didn't get it.
They can't take it down.
And I don't know the challenge of that.
I'm not saying it's easy,
but I certainly feel like we have to,
you still have to walk around in society,
you know,
unless we,
what do we just housing.
I felt players in a separate property and you know like in the sort of keep them
away from general population,
but think it's something that the people that are involved in the sport from a
high school to college coaches to everyone.
It's something that's not addressed,
but it's one of the most difficult aspects of competitive athletics,
sports combat,
sports as it were.
Yeah.
I consider football combat sport.
Absolutely.
You know what I mean?
Those guys are fucking run and knew each other full clip.
But if that's not comment,
what the fuck has no,
it absolutely.
Yeah.
So I think that just the realities of dealing with being a combat athlete or any
sort of explosive athlete,
you're dealing with physical contact on a regular basis,
call it whatever you want that that's,
it's hard to be a functional member of a calm stayed normal society on top of
doing that.
At the same time he had the,
and just especially like the w like you're saying like to me I always think
about the fact that these guys,
again,
it's like the professional athletes have been since high school now since
seventh or eighth grade been sort of,
the rules
had been changed and they've been coddled and you you don't have to go clean.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You don't have to go to class.
Well you don't have to do these things and you don't,
and so sometimes they don't get the life skills that a regular person would get
because they've been sort of segregated from regular society and you give
somebody $1 million and tell him that they're the best and like the same thing.
I,
I feel the same way about comedy sometimes I come off stage after our goods that
I feel like I am the best thing this world has ever seen.
Well that's definitely an issue with like sitcoms,
stars.
Yeah.
That's a big issue,
man.
I've been around people that like run their own shows.
They have their own Sitcom,
they're yelling at the producer and yelling at the other actors and yelling at
everyone.
And I mean there's,
there's a hundred stories of like,
you know,
Roseanne,
when she was running the Roseanne show,
Brett Butler when she was on grace under fire.
And it's like you can go on and on and on.
There's a million different stories that have to do with people that become the
star of a show.
It's the Kamau bell show.
I mean,
there were everybody shut the fuck up.
Well,
I'm sure if we brought in some of the staff and totally buys,
they would tell you stories about me like that,
you know?
And not that I,
I sir.
It's when you are putting a position where you're the focus,
everybody's attention for all day long,
every day.
I can say it tweaks your head.
Like it tweaked my head in a way that I certainly was not,
I don't think I,
Brett Butler did ever,
Roseanne did,
but,
and maybe I should have.
Sometimes I should have because I think sometimes you have to sort of go,
everybody pay attention.
But I certainly was not the best version of myself.
And that's one thing that when I left I felt like,
all right,
I can sort of figure,
I can return back to that dude who got the show in the first place.
Well also a producer who comes up with a wacky idea that make would make you
look bad.
It doesn't hurt him.
If he,
if you,
if he talks you into doing this wacky idea and you're like,
this wacky idea sucks.
No,
no,
no.
Listen,
we talked this through.
Just give it a shot to play ball with her.
Yeah.
You're going to let you do that thing on rape jokes like you to do this thing
where you,
you know,
you put fucking blackface on.
Yeah.
But you know what I mean?
No,
I know exactly what you mean.
Yeah.
Do it.
And it doesn't work.
You look like a fucking idiot.
They don't feel anything.
And I think there's also this thing where people think fit.
There's a like people,
I think there's this weird thing in the entertainment issue now where some
people like they still don't get the internet and they go,
well you like it used to be Johnny Carson on the tonight show and did a stupid
thing that made you feel stupid.
Nobody ever could even do it.
See it again.
It was gone.
It was in the annals of time.
But I'm like,
no,
this exists forever.
Like if you make me do something stupid that I don't like to do,
I will be hearing about it for the rest of my life on some level.
Yeah,
no doubt.
No doubt.
I think that's the thing you were saying about like it just becomes this thing
where it's a sea change.
You know it's also this different time hasn't,
they haven't caught up to the reality of it yet.
Like one of the things about your show is you had a late night show but late
night shows have become,
they've,
they've had,
they have this sort of symbiotic relationship with the Internet now because one
of the big things is getting a clip that people find about online and they,
you know,
Facebook,
it back and forth to each other and you go,
oh listen to this cool,
funny thing that Conan did,
you know,
and then we'll get this skit.
Yeah,
look,
yeah.
And that becomes a great way to get people aware of the show.
So it's almost like the time that it's on is not nearly as important as the fact
that it's being made.
And what the,
I ran into him,
my shows,
cause I wasn't,
I didn't grow up wanting to,
because I read every book,
the late books that Bill Carter Road,
all those dudes grew up wanting to be late night talk show host like Conan and
Kimmel and they all kids.
Letterman was a hero and Carson was their hero.
I didn't grow up that way.
I grew up,
Chris Rock was my hero.
You know what I mean?
Like I want to be a standup and he had a show on HBO then I was like,
I want it.
But it wasn't,
nobody thought it was a late night shows the Chris rock show.
Right?
I mean Stuart,
I like Stuart.
Like that's hits the Jon Stewart show.
It's not a late night talk show,
but once I got put in that world,
suddenly there was this thing about like,
do you have any famous friends we could put on here who could come in here?
Like the way that Fallon does a thing with Justin Timberlake and Fallon was on
SNL for eight years.
Like he knows his Rolodex is filled with everybody.
I was in the bay area,
you know,
I don't have the ability to reach out to this pain near a meth sign.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
I was not going,
man.
I'm not going to crystal meth and I'll call the guy from the poster.
I'll call the the Asian twink from the poster to come on the show.
But yeah,
be careful.
You can't say twink Andy Collin got in trouble for saying twink.
Oh is that?
Well,
I certainly,
I feel like I'm calling them that because that's the,
they were portraying it was that way.
I'm not saying that all areas are twins.
Twink you not allowed to use it anymore and decided not to say that one.
The guy that had a bravo who's,
oh yeah,
no,
yeah,
I got in trouble for saying someone's a perfect twink.
It's preposterous.
Well,
it's,
it's again,
it's everybody seeing everybody's shit.
Well,
they used to be that you could only,
you only saw your shit and the shit you interested in.
So,
and when you're the head of a network,
it's a totally different deal.
It's not like I said it and somebody may tweeted me and told me,
I have to say,
and I'm like,
oh,
but I'm not responsible for billions of dollars.
If someone does tweet you and tells you not retweet the shit out of that,
what do you mean that to let people know that everybody in that little cool look
at this,
talk to this guy.
Yeah.
I mean,
I've let people react,
said people.
I mean,
I,
the thing I like to do that when people say shitty things to me that I think are
actually just shitty and not helpful.
I,
I've turned a few people,
I've,
uh,
I've made people apologize.
Just,
yeah,
just out of sheer,
like I kido sort of like taking their energy and putting it in the wall and
then,
and then bringing them back to you and do it again,
and then we just put it back in the wall and then they go,
yeah,
you're right.
You're pretty good guy.
I was probably out of luck.
Like that's my favorite thing to do is to turn people on Twitter.
Don't you think that a lot of people are doing it just to get your attention?
There?
Absolutely are.
But that's why I think it's fun if you can actually make them feel bad for
getting your attention and,
but not from like calling them now from yelling at them,
but from taking their energy and sort of like,
actually sometimes people will say,
I'm not shitting you actually treat it like it's serious and well,
that's,
you know,
and they go,
no,
I'm just,
I'm trying to listen to what you're saying.
Like they,
and they get frustrated because you're not mad.
And I like to win.
Not that I do is,
it's like when I'm on the road and I'm by myself,
it's like,
all right,
let's,
uh,
it's not,
I'm not yelling at them.
I'm fucking with them back
in a way that they don't realize that,
that you should be mad.
No.
Now they know.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Your strategy,
some fucking news of attack.
We'll see what happens.
I'm ready for it.
Or I'll just ignore it.
I'll just ignore it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Some new matador tactics you're going to have to come up with.
Yeah.
Dealing with people online is amazing.
It's a,
it's an amazing thing that no one was prepared for that you know,
interacting with people on message boards,
on Twitter,
on Facebook and all these different,
if we had this at the beginning of the United States of America,
we wouldn't be in the future right now.
We'd still be in like wagons and buggies like I feel like it's ticket.
It is slowing down progress.
By the time they were all spinning,
arguing about bullshit online.
Don't you think though that,
look,
I don't agree with a lot of the social justice warriors and their tactics and
the professional victim mentality that a lot of them portray,
but in I feel like our student for good people,
I feel like social justice people and professional victims.
I just think that's isn't that two different groups of people?
It can be.
Okay.
All right.
Point is like really whiny,
overly sensitive,
super progressive,
aggressive people.
I think though that it opens up the dialogue and forces people to even,
even if you're communicating about it in a way where you're defending your
position,
that that conversation gets like a perfect one.
The perfect subject is a,
this subject is coming up a lot lately,
uh,
where a lot of feminists are trying to push the idea that if a person has sex
with someone that's been drinking,
that it's rape,
they're saying yes,
they're saying you can't consent,
including men.
They're saying a woman having sex with a drunk man,
she's raping that man because he,
he's not able to consent because he's drinking.
Um,
I think it's ridiculous.
I think there's,
some of us wouldn't be here without exactly sex.
Not only that,
there's a giant spectrum of what intoxication is.
Also,
it takes away a lot of responsibility where you are forced to be responsible for
your actions.
If you're driving,
you're forced to be responsible for your actions.
If you engage in a violent activity,
but somehow or another,
if you're drinking and someone had sex with you,
you were raped the same amount of intoxication that you would be liable for
driving liable for violent actions.
Now you're not liable for your actions.
It seems ridiculous.
And it also,
it's,
it discredits women in a lot of ways because you're saying that they,
they're not capable of forming their own decisions and deciding that they want
to have a couple of drinks and fuck some guy because you know,
women do that.
They will have,
if you need a couple of days where you fuck some guy just to it because
otherwise you're not gonna wanna fuck that guy.
And it's fun and it's Friday evening and he had a hard week.
Exactly.
He's not the good looking guy.
You thought you'd meet at the bar.
Yeah.
And they're having a good time mean there's not always a negative thing.
And that's the problem with broad strokes like painting with broad strokes.
But in introducing this dialog and discussion and making people angry about this
debate,
they are bringing up the very real situation of people drugging people and
getting people drunk and having sex with him,
which is disgusting and is rape and is immoral.
So I think even in like when they pushed
the needle way too far to the left though,
I think that balances out a little bit.
The point is that you sometimes you can't,
it's like the thing where if you go,
hey,
can we talk about a rape?
Nah,
can wait just for a second.
Talking about Nano Tech.
Okay.
It's not that big of a deal.
Yeah,
you have to.
You can't.
And I think this is certainly is as the culture of oppressed people,
is it the culture of repress being oppressed in America is that people don't
hear you when you ask permission for the science,
but people don't hear you when you say,
I'd like to talk about racism in America and just see if we can finally,
nobody wants to hear that.
So you have to,
I love when there's people sometimes so far because the right is filled with
people who are so far on the right and don't,
and they're always like barking and people can get a lot of attention.
The left is historically been ashamed of that.
Like we don't want to get too loud and we ride.
And so for me it's like we need a couple of those people who are,
who,
who make,
who shows where the middle should be.
You know,
who was like so far,
okay,
we don't want to do that.
But like you said,
the pendulum has to be pushed that far to get it back to the middle.
Yeah,
no doubt.
And I,
well I don't know if it has to be,
but it aids in that.
I think,
I mean this is an example of a little example of it.
Like people will say that occupy Wall Street didn't accomplish anything.
However,
we didn't talk about the words income inequality ever in this country until
occupy Wall Street.
Well,
it introduced the frame,
the frame of the 1% and so people say it didn't accomplish a thing it,
but by going to the parks and sitting out and getting your bond goes out and you
know,
in a,
in,
in knitting for justice or whatever and feeding people and giving out books.
Now that is in the,
people will say people on the right,
we'll say income inequality and the 1% not realizing that they've adopted the
speech of the left.
You know?
And so sometimes you have to have a Tantrum to get some attention.
And I think coming from a historically black people,
we are used to like,
okay,
we need to have a tantrum.
Sometimes that Tantrum is inventing rock and roll and sometimes it's a million
men march.
You know?
It's just,
that's the,
that's the nature of being,
of getting attention to Americans in a press group.
Well,
it's also the first time ever where people can uniquely start a movement online
can,
they don't need like an office somewhere where they hire a bunch of people or I
need to know anybody or even see anybody personally who that who is helping them
make the movement happen.
I mean,
this is happening all the time.
This climate march on DM on New York City,
they fucking clogged up the streets,
man.
Yeah,
yeah.
On the climate,
nobody is,
that's not a sexy issue.
Nobody is like,
well,
you know that's not,
but they got the word out and made people think is important,
which I believe it is,
but it's also a thing where it's like as a person who's like,
I have other issues that I'd like to see the streets clogged up with,
but okay,
that's,
I'm glad we're getting the streets clogged.
Yeah,
well it's a fascinating time when you see these movements and they see how big
they are and right now nonviolent peaceful.
But the government be sure is aware that this could also be a large protest.
It turns violent.
I can overthrow the government type protest.
I mean look,
this guy that just fucking broken to the White House other day,
the guy half the fence,
oh man,
like 900 rounds of Ammo in his car,
duck tape and fucking just climbed the fence and ran.
I mean,
I hate when it's like,
it wasn't even like a ocean's 11 plan.
It was like it was just the,
I'm just going to climb the fence and run and get to the door fucking door.
How many I,
it's so hard to feel like how many,
what is happening?
There's got it.
There's multiple levels of security at the White House.
It's not just one guy who was like,
I didn't see him.
It's fucking,
it's not the greeter at Walmart.
Like you know how many levels of secure have to break down for him to get into
the White House and why is that happening?
Do they suck?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And why is my question in the era of the black president,
why does this have to be with us today sucked in the era of the Bush presidency.
Yeah.
But I just feel like just take it more to the same thing happened.
The guy broke into the White House and got in the White House lawn when the
Bush,
when Bush was president as well playing into the White House,
right?
No,
that was the Pentagon.
What are you talking about when like are a small plane like a,
not like a real long time ago though,
wasn't it?
When was that?
Google that shit.
I don't know.
But hold that.
Shaming the fence and running and getting in the front door.
To me,
the problem with that is there's no sophistication to that.
That should be the easiest thing.
Unleashed the hounds.
All right.
We're done with that.
Yeah.
Well they'd have to be on point 24 seven looking at for any,
there was another woman that
got shot recently.
Yeah.
Then the woman gets shot.
She,
she showed up at the White House and our car and broke through a barrier that
they,
you said they have to be on point in 12 hours.
I think they're supposed to be.
Yes.
I think that's the Gig,
but the point is that these movements that you see like in New York City where
the clog in the streets,
that could easily happen at the White House.
Yeah.
That's fucking terrifying for them.
If a million people just stormed the White House and tore it to the ground,
stomped to death,
I'll just fucking secret service agents were holding their heads up to the of
like that.
That shit is not outside the realm of possibility if everything goes horribly
wrong.
Well,
no,
not really.
I mean,
you know,
Isis is doing a good job recruiting people right now with some Hollywood style
videos.
And you know,
if somebody in America picked up that ball,
you know,
I think that's what the White House is afraid of right now.
Is it clearly isis or Isol,
whatever you call it,
is recruiting from here.
We've got a Middle East,
not just,
not very many,
but at least it's,
it's,
it's stirring the pot here in a way.
Nobody thought al Qaeda was recruiting firm.
It was like,
oh,
going to get American people to do every now and again,
there was one,
but this is like actually there's a sense that they are recruited that like
there was that in that video that they released,
there's the one shot of,
of uh,
like a cell phone video of somebody driving past the White House and shooting
video of the White House,
which everybody can do.
But the fact it was in the isis videos like,
oh shit,
it's a,
it implies something that is not.
But yeah,
I think we,
we,
we could do that.
But until we,
the,
the only way that happens in America is you have to make it seem legitimate and
you have to make it sexy.
Occupy Wall Street became sexy for,
for a few months if we need like an ice bucket challenge.
The ice bucket challenge did it,
I'm going to,
I going to scale the White House and I challenge 94
man killed and suicidal plane crash in the white now.
So that was Clinton.
Yeah.
Wow.
Get it across the cell phone.
Crazy.
Fuck yeah.
Goofy bastard looking at it was porn mustache.
Yeah.
Playing is different though because you can't like,
oh the plane coming.
It's coming at us.
But a dude who's like climbing the fence.
I just seem so like last minute and not low tech.
Yeah.
That shit,
that's not well thought out and it should not be a thing that he got to the
White House door.
Should have been,
I'm over the fence.
Oh my God,
the dogs are eating me.
Oh well this didn't go well.
It must be that scene in casino when they talk about the most or ocean's 11 the
most successful bank,
Robbie,
right robber or Vegas Heiss robberies and it's only people who got to the door
like,
you know,
like that's what should happen.
It should be a thing where you get inside.
Well there's more money in Vegas than there is.
And guarding the White House.
Yes.
Certainly the mob,
despite his quite as except still runs Vegas,
the mob is not running the White House anymore.
If they were,
it would be a tighter ship.
Yes.
I'm all for,
I'm all for that.
With no consequences.
Yes.
Yeah.
And it wouldn't kill the guy on the spot.
They drag them into the house first.
Yeah,
they talked to them.
They have a conversation with them first.
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't think in our lifetime we're gonna,
I don't know if we're going to ever see like some sort of a,
a crazy million group of people that are storming the government like we saw in
Egypt like we saw in Libya.
I don't know.
I don't,
I think it,
we'd have to really get to a strange place to make that happen,
to get that many people on the same page.
You will also have that kind of,
cause even the tea party and the further right versions of that aren't doing
that.
They have all the guns but they're not prepared to do that with them.
And also there's no,
I mean besides September 11th there's no notable attacks on America in America.
This Pearl Harbor,
which is sort of America.
Yes.
Sort of America.
Yeah.
Flying five hours in a plane over the ocean doesn't really seem like American to
me,
although I love Hawaii.
Uh,
but the difference between that and September 11th September 11th like,
okay,
this is actually happening in Ameritech more things happening in America and we
think it's a direct result of mismanagement.
Miss Government,
you know,
corruption,
what have you,
and people die and you know,
Chicago is blown off the face of the map.
Some ugly shit could go down,
but it's,
yeah,
but that you,
you,
you're talking about like a post apocalyptic,
you know like a blade runner type of like that's not,
that's not something that we're,
we're separate.
We're steps away from,
there are several steps away if we are several steps,
but that's one of the reasons why people will never give up their fucking guns.
It's one,
one of the reasons why people think like this shit could always happen.
I want to be locked and loaded with a bunch of water in my basement.
Some potatoes,
standby for tags,
bags
with the thing where I can clean my urine so I can drink it.
Yeah.
Super Britta filter.
When is that?
I mean I'm not,
I'm not trying to take away people's guns away,
but when has a cache of guns stop the government from taking anybody down if
they wanted to take them down?
It depends.
Depends on how many guns and how many people,
but I'm saying we haven't seen it happen.
You know when they're,
when they decide to come get you,
you know Ruby Ridge
or Waco,
they go get the tank with the fire.
That'll stop the semi automatic machine guns.
He wasn't trying to take down the government.
He was trying to bang everybody's pay,
but as I'm saying,
when they're like,
when they're and that they,
he wasn't even doing things that were necessarily,
he wasn't killing people in,
they went,
they were just like get the tank with the fire.
That'll settle this,
that'll take care of this.
You know what,
you can't fence in your town and then like have tanks and guns and ammo and the
government's like that seems a little too much like a small country.
You fuck.
Yeah,
we know we're not a bad and I'm not for the government ruling everything.
I just think that the thing that you see in Egypt and in the Ukraine is that if
people storm the streets,
it doesn't matter how many tanks do you have.
People just go and I always say that like the problem with American protest is
they have an end time and it's posted on Facebook.
We are going to be in the streets until five 30 right.
Whereas in the Ukraine,
in Egypt,
like,
no,
we're just going to stay.
We're just not going anywhere.
And I know that Americans have that.
I mean,
have that kind of follow through.
Eventually you're like,
I'd like to get home and watch some Netflix is on tonight and I'm going to order
take out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I got to pick up my kid from soccer practice.
The fucking baby shit man.
Well that's,
isn't that the goal of being an American and being allowed to be as soft as baby
shit?
Isn't that the why we,
why people struggle to get here?
Why kids are streaming across the border?
Because it's hard living here.
So why we got a two five terrorism over there.
It doesn't come over here.
So you can avoid your Chinese food and enjoy your soccer practice.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's why we need guns.
That's why we need to get,
we got to understand the second amendment.
Second Amendment.
Yeah.
I'll show it to you.
It was written on the animal skins collaborate here.
Yeah,
but God wrote the second amendment.
I don't think that's how that worked.
The shit was written in the 17 hundreds and everybody's clinging to it.
That's the hilarious thing about the constitution in general that is written
like this is unconstitutional.
Yes.
What?
The fucking constitution is old as shit.
Well,
as I understand it is,
I was taught in a,
in a high school American history class when they wrote it,
they were like,
this will just set the country up for about 20 years and then we'll come back
and look at this like,
this is just the,
we are done with the British.
We've got to make sure they don't come back.
So we need militias just in case they show up again.
But this is just to get us started and it became sacrosanct.
It became like this is the,
it became another chapter of the Bible.
Well,
once the people who wrote it are dead,
you don't ever want to fuck with it because then it's like a religious doctrine.
Yeah.
And that's the problem is that it w religious doctrine,
religious doctrines aren't religious doctrines.
They're all written by a dude named Jeff,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm on somebody who was like,
yeah,
yeah.
It's always like,
I just want to,
you know,
it's like Chris Rock Creek,
Chris Rock,
bit about it.
Like people,
like people said,
God said it because if you say,
I said it,
people don't listen,
so yeah.
So yeah,
pork will kill you.
They don't listen.
God said,
portal key.
Okay,
we'll stop eating pork.
You know,
people like to be told they have authority and I'm not.
And I said,
this is somebody who's not.
I'm,
I'm not an,
I'm not an atheist.
I'm not a,
I'm not anti,
I'm not anti religion.
I'd certainly think religion done a lot of shitty things,
but I'm not sitting here as an atheist going,
I don't believe in any of it.
What are you,
if you're not an atheist,
do you consider yourself an agnostic?
Are you religious?
No,
I'm not really,
I mean,
I grew up Christian.
I feel like,
I feel like I come from a Christian base.
Like I like I was black church Methodist church,
Baptist church,
so I can't help but retreat to that.
Sometimes when the shit hits the fan could,
you know,
oh Jesus help like,
but I don't expect them to walk through the door,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not,
I don't believe that there is a guy in heaven looking down on me,
but I do like to think of the universe as being in a place where it,
where if you,
if you live a good life and have ordered that things will work out for you.
And so,
and certainly I will retreat to,
you know,
I like to think that I just,
it makes me feel comforted to go,
thanks God,
but I'm not going before we get started,
let's have a prayer.
You know what I'm saying?
It's culturally,
God has been a cultured,
I've been in like culture with God and it doesn't,
and it seems to have worked out,
but I don't want to go to church.
I don't want to,
I don't feel a mild form of Christianity.
I have a mom like it's like it's a,
it's like a piece that you don't need to take Valtrex for.
It's exactly what it is.
I have tried just fine.
It doesn't usually hurt anybody.
I let everybody know it's just,
and I only say that because I feel like I can have the atheism discussion and
not feel threatened by uh,
who have to tell me there's not a god cause it breaks my whole,
no,
this is my own in the same way that some people,
their god is good,
you know,
game of Thrones,
they like think that's the thing,
you know,
that's,
we all of us have gods that we've defined is like I'm living my life.
Comicon is religion for people.
But,
but we somehow,
if you actually say the really do don't you just think as a gathering,
a fun gathering.
Like,
but that's what religion started out as.
It was just,
it was a way to centralize the community and get people on the same page about
stuff.
And some of those things are moral.
And I get,
have you been to comic con?
He must've.
I've been outside of comicon.
I've never gone into comic.
If you went into comic con,
you wouldn't ask this question.
I went there,
I went in there.
It's,
it's for real like people,
this is like people's lives,
isn't it?
Because they get the freedom to have fun and be a freak because like most of the
time society frowns upon you dressing like an anime character.
Most of the time you can't be a furry,
you can't be iron man.
You can't,
you can't just be there and be hanging out with people having a good time.
Well,
I think it is that,
but it's also those people,
they,
they go there because that's the place where they're permitted to have it,
but they're living at the whole year.
Sometimes they're just just like a furry in their house,
you know what I'm saying?
But then that's where they go.
It's like,
you know,
it's like Christmas,
we're allowed to hang the lights and do all the shit that and it's just fun.
But then some people also carried the,
have a cross on their wall.
You know?
I don't think there's much difference ultimately between a Spiderman poster on
your wall.
If then across on your wall,
if that's the thing that you're focused on,
you know,
that'd be hilarious.
I Spiderman is your God.
Yes,
there's certainly,
and I live in San Francisco where people,
I've lived as her people are hyperfocused about their version of their life.
Like,
I want to live my life this way.
I want to go to this coffee shop and I want to,
and I,
and I go to this bar and I,
and I do leather things on the weekend and I go to the Folsom street fair and
that,
and that to me,
it's like that's your religion.
You than he,
that's the thing that makes you feel better about the world and that's how you
put order in the world.
But you're not,
and you're,
God may be,
uh,
that,
you know,
that I'm going to live the best gay lifestyle I have or that I'm going to be the
best,
you know,
whatever.
There's all,
we all have gods,
we just don't want to put that word on them.
So for me,
my God is actually,
I put the word God in there cause I don't want to be a hypocrite and be like,
I'm like,
basically when I went and I met my wife,
she was a religious studies major.
She was in graduate school for that.
And I was like,
I did the thing that everybody says,
I'm not religious,
I'm spiritual.
She's like,
that's full of Shit,
you know,
and take us,
what do you,
what do you believe?
And I was like,
I guess I believe in God.
But it's like if you say that people start to get quiet,
like you guys are getting quiet right now.
I'm letting you talk.
No,
no.
I know.
I'm just fucking around.
But yes,
don't see the,
the,
the connection between Spiderman and God.
I think Spiderman is something you enjoy.
God is something you believe in that doesn't necessarily have any basis,
in fact,
or in provable,
uh,
you,
you can't prove the existence of God.
You can't,
there's nothing,
there's nothing that you can point to in science that says,
well,
we can't explain this.
We're pretty sure that what this is is God's work.
But there's certainly,
there's,
that's the thing and I feel very comfortable and not because I'm not trying to
convince you guys,
I feel very comfortable and not being able to approve the thing that is that I
sort of walk around with it.
But listen,
you don't have to,
I mean,
it's a framework for,
you know,
moral judgments.
It's a framework for discipline.
It can give you sort of a path to lead your life in a positive manner.
There's nothing wrong with religion,
but it's not iron man.
But,
but I think,
I believe that we all know that there are things that we put in our,
and I'm not,
I'm not,
this isn't even criticize them,
it's just there are things that people put in their life like I don't believe in
God.
And then you see that they spent,
what will,
whatever you're spending the most time doing that you feel like is making you a
better person.
You are.
That's,
that's your God.
That's your,
that's your religion.
That's we are inventing our own religion.
Well,
religion maybe.
Yeah.
Okay.
Like ideologies,
religions.
They're very similar.
I mean,
I feel like your religion is PR.
You got a little,
it may religion happening to know like where thanks,
I go to the gym,
I work out,
I'm bonding.
This is my community.
I bond with these people.
I feel better because I come here.
There's a code of honor here and a code of ethics that if somebody violates,
we talked to that person about it or if it that's that's,
and I'm not trying to make anybody feel,
this is just my belief.
I'm not trying to say it,
just we you have that life that this is how I live my life and this is how I
want to live my life.
It's just we've taken the God thing out of it because God cause people fuck the
gut.
People treated that turf,
turned that into a bed and turned into a shouting thing.
You know,
I'm not,
I will make fun of boarding and Christians all day long.
I'm not trying to say that that's the way to do it,
but for me,
I think because I grew up that way in the,
like there was a lot of church around my life.
I projected the church.
But I also would like to,
if I'm,
if I'm running for the bus and I get it,
sometimes they go,
oh,
thank God.
And I don't know.
You know what I mean?
Like,
and I just,
and I know that I'm,
but I don't expect that I'd be like,
I got you dog.
I don't,
I don't expect to see the guy,
you know?
I see what you're saying.
Like it's just,
it's in me,
it's a part of my,
it's uh,
it's part of my ethnicity is black religion.
It can be empowering,
you know,
to,
to have a belief.
And that belief doesn't necessarily have to be even based on fact in order for
it to benefit you.
No,
no.
And that's the problem is,
is that if you go,
this is what I believe,
and I'm gonna sit here until you two guys believe it.
Well,
not only that,
like,
guess what?
I can't disprove it either.
The reality is I've seen way more fucked up shit doing psychedelic drugs and
anybody has ever described in the Bible,
you know,
if you go to heaven and it's just a guy with a harp and angels and Saint Peter's
really at the pearly gates and the floor's made out of clouds.
Yeah,
like that would be so normal in comparison to like a DMT trip.
Like that shit would be like pretty mundane.
And I feel like people talk about proof all the time.
I don't know why this phone fucking works,
but they could figure that out.
They could figure it out.
I need to talk to someone educated,
but nobody's gonna explain it to me in a way that I could take it apart and
putting it back together.
You know what I'm saying?
They could,
they would just take a long,
but that's what I'm saying.
But I don't care.
I don't need to know what I'm saying.
I trusted,
there's people,
there's children in China who know what they're doing and they put the phone
together.
But if you wanted to chase that down to the very origins of the first seed that
makes the first phone,
you could do that and I,
and the same way,
I don't have interest in doing that.
I don't have interest in convincing anybody else about my version of God.
Like as I say on stage,
when I say God,
I picture a really old Denzel Washington with dreadlocks,
but just that's how it is in my head.
That's how I feel about it.
What about a,
didn't Morgan Freeman play God and move in a Prince George?
This has been a few old dude.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
mine is specifically Denzel Washington.
That's specifically why Denzel,
he's like sort of,
I mean,
a friend of mine taught me,
he's kind of like a surrogate dad,
like Denzel Washington.
I don't know him,
but in the movies,
there was a period of my life where like I felt like Denzel was,
it helped me figure it out.
He's a,
he's the last black actor in Hollywood who is sort of carrying the baton for
this as how to be a black man.
You know what?
I'm saying and that's an important thing to have in the black community,
especially when you grow up.
Like I have known who my dad is.
I've met him several times and I'm fucking around.
I'd know when I used to visit in the summer,
but I didn't grow up with a deal with my dad in the house.
And so I found surrogate dads and places in entertainment who I felt like this
is a person that she tried to be like Bruce Lee was a surrogate dad of mine.
You know,
like,
uh,
that just showed me that again,
helping me learn a moral code and giving me an example of how to be an adult and
how to be a man.
Yeah,
I had the same,
I had a martial arts instructor that did something for me.
I did martial arts instructor who did it for me.
There's this thing about movies and like having someone who may be even as an
unrealistic depiction of a human being,
like so moral and ethical and powerful and strong,
but that that can be empowering.
If you want to be like Denzel Washington,
you want to get some more coffee?
It makes them more tomorrow.
I'm sorry.
Let me just hop on a double stream.
Do Special Magic coffees and got me,
got me rolling.
It's good shit.
I uh,
I never thought too much about racism and movies or thought about black people
being represented in movies until I went to see planet of the apes and a black
neighborhood and Philly and,
uh,
the first,
the James Franco plant of the apes.
And uh,
I was with my friend Tommy and his girlfriend Kate,
and we were in Philly for the UFC and a Friday nights,
the weigh ins.
So we do the way ends on Friday and then we had Friday night off.
And so we want to do,
hey,
plant of the apes is out,
let's go check it out.
So,
uh,
we were in the hotel room.
We got high as Jesus on the space shuttle.
I mean,
we went way too deep.
We went way too deep.
And then we went out to this movie theater and the closest movie theater was in
this all black neighborhood in Philly.
And so I mean,
I mean all blacks.
I mean we were the only fucking white,
whatever,
America's last few,
all of them,
but fun.
Yeah.
God Damn it was fun.
But here's the thing,
man,
when I was in that movie theater,
I was acutely aware of first of all that we were the only white people in there.
And I was also acutely aware that every fucking ad for every preview,
every movie was white people.
It was all white people.
And I was like,
whoa.
But being in that position,
like having that perspective of being a white person and an all black movie
theater,
I was like,
whoa.
And being high as fuck made me super sensitive to it.
And there was only one white guy that interacted with a black guy and all the
previews and it was Jonah Hill and some fucking goofy ass movie about playing a
babysitter where he brings the kids and talk to this black doorman and he's
talking to a women this like really fucking depressing slang buddy.
Oh,
it was so bad.
And then the,
the,
the black guy says to him like,
you're a bad motherfucker.
I'm like,
what?
Yeah,
world is this taking place in.
And it was,
it was so bizarre.
Then plant of the apes place and everyone in the movie is white except the bad
guy.
He's a black guy who fucking forces the,
the drugs to get into the monkeys and then the monkeys go loose and take over
the world and I'm like,
Whoa,
this is real shit.
Yeah,
everybody should get that high.
Every white person can then hang,
go see and go live in the world because that's what it does.
Everything you said is like,
I'm like,
uh Huh.
Yes.
Keeps it yet did nothing and not surprised.
Well also that scenario,
that particular scenario was unique.
It was very unique because it was like the perfect storm of shitty preview after
shitty preview and all of them with white people.
You know Cameron,
what's her name was Cameron Diaz.
Diaz.
Yeah.
Cameron Diaz and Oh my God,
man,
Da Da.
And find a man and the black people in the audience just stone faced watching
these previews waiting.
No one's laughing as they shouldn't.
There's the most depressing thing ever is when you go to the movies and the
previous look like dog
shit and someone's laughing out.
Ah,
we got to see that to see how Melissa Mccartney falls down.
Oh,
she's hilarious.
She's big.
So pink girl.
My oldest.
When people funny when,
when,
uh,
when it's a stone face like that and then slowly people laugh at it like they're
solely,
the audience are still,
they're not laughing with it.
They're laughing at then San Francisco sometimes if people are like,
they're actually like,
no,
we're laughing at you movie when I left.
We're not going to go see where this is ridiculous bullshit.
You've put it before us.
That is beautiful.
That's when you know you're in a good neighborhood.
Good neighborhood to be in.
That's a lot of laughter at the trailers.
That's the crowds I want to perform in the crowds.
It laugh at the trailers I on Jonah Hill,
see if you could find that fucking preview Jonah Hill in the babysitter or
something.
Some shit like that.
Oh,
so for me,
I remember the time I off,
I remember where I just felt like you just,
why don't you just let me down.
It was Steve Martin in the movie with Queen Latifa and we're like some sort of
thing where she's the Blah Blah Blah and he's the bla bla bla.
And together they got the book trailers.
Just her being a very outsized version of a black woman in him being a very
narrow version of white guy.
And in the middle of it,
Steve Martin,
one of the greatest comedians of all time who has it was on the,
oh he was in the comedy hall of fame,
does a thing where he walks through a black club,
all gangs,
like sort of all gangster it out in like a jersey.
And he's walking like a quote unquote black.
And I'm like,
Nah,
you Steve Martin,
you're the one of the greatest,
you know there's a mortgage.
Yeah,
he's got a busy mind dollar house.
that's the movie.
Yeah,
and see if you can find that video.
We got to see this video because it's so fucking bad.
He's like the wacky crazy babies and by the way,
I'm a Jonah Hill Fan.
I watched that it all black and movie theater stone to the Gills and I went,
Whoa,
what a cartoonish buffoonish representation of black people and this is the only
one they get to see and the finding is is people will say,
why are black people are,
why are some black people so angry?
And I feel like we,
they did the people in that theater you then,
because we have to let shit wash over us for the rest will be angry all the time
and we will be outwardly like flipping tables all the time.
If we don't,
if we don't sort of go,
we just got to wait for planet of the apes.
We just got to let this wash over us.
We can't turn.
We can't turn this into a change.org petition.
We just got to let this go.
Well,
it's also,
you're not,
you'd never dealing with things from a neutral point because you're dealing with
things from the,
the repercussions of all the other shit that you've seen already before that.
And the thing is is it has been stated by many people.
Is that in this country?
Nope.
The most people watching those trailers that you saw aren't going,
these are a bunch of white people in these trailers.
They're going,
those are a bunch of people in these trailers.
But then if you show the trailer for,
you know,
Friday after next,
then it's a bunch of black people in those trays because white is considered to
be normal in this country.
That's the white is the default.
It's like on the census,
which is you upload the census form.
The first category when they hit on the race category,
the list of races is white.
So it's not alphabetical.
It's just white.
Okay.
White.
And then if you're not that,
what else are you,
and it's like white people are busy.
We got to,
you need to go with,
you know,
so it's the white is considered the default.
And when people say things like,
like I've talked about this before,
like people magazine is about white people for the most part,
but essence says it's a black magazine,
right?
You know,
it's,
it's very,
but what,
and I feel like white people,
one way to sort of put less racism or is white people have to start putting
white on their magazines.
I have to start.
If white people got more comfortable with talking about their whiteness,
it would make the rest of us not look crazy when we talked about her ethnicity.
But sometimes when I go as a black man,
people go,
well how do you have to white people can't.
If white people talk about their ethnicity,
if white people say we're going to have the white actors awards,
Dude,
well that's a problem.
Shit would not cause some white people,
it's wouldn't fly because white,
when people's,
historically in this country,
when people identify themselves as white,
it's the clan or it's neo Nazis and I feel like good white people like
yourselves have to have to take whiteness back.
Thank you for including me in the group.
I appreciate that very much.
You know what someone said to me also is that white power,
like Brown,
Brown pride is a tattoo that Cain Velasquez,
Hassan and nobody came to Alaska as the heavyweight champion of the world.
No one gives him a hard time for having brown pride tattooed on his chest
because he said he's proud to be Mexican,
but if you had white pride tattooed on your chest,
that's a different animal.
So I said this to my friend and he was like,
yeah,
but you know what?
You could have Irish pride.
And I was like,
Ooh,
that's so true.
And you could have Irish pride tattooed on your chest.
You know what?
The differences,
I mean average people that have not been known to be like slave masters and not
been known to be KKK members.
It's not like a traditional background for them.
It's,
it's all,
yeah.
And I think it's also,
it's about the,
there's a nationality there versus white.
White was an invented concept in this country.
You know what I mean?
Like you're in Europe,
they don't,
they think racist.
They don't think racism exists in Europe because it's all about now it's like
the French hate the Spanish.
It's not,
they don't really white.
This is the thing,
we don't have racism.
Yeah.
But you still have nationalism.
Weird Shit.
And over they're like,
it's okay to hate Arabs.
That's different.
But uh,
but in this country,
white became this invented concept.
And the reason why white power is hard for people to take is because white
people already got the power when he,
when Cain Velasquez attached says Brown pride is because Brown people don't feel
like they've got enough power.
And it's a way to invoke a feeling of power and invoke the thing that Brown
people who have been shit on.
And I'm going to take the power back.
Black power came out of black people going,
we're tired of being shit on.
So we're going to say black power,
white power.
You got it.
White people,
you got it done.
Didn't fuck.
And so when the white people for white power on it feels like,
wait,
how much power are you going to tell?
It's like,
yeah,
just cause then it becomes about we don't want you in our schools,
we don't want black people in our schools are bumpy when our school like these
can we go to,
can't we see or we don't want you drinking out of our water fountain.
You know what I mean?
It becomes this,
the power gives so crazy.
But I believe,
and I'm,
I got a kid who's half white that if white people,
good white people actually reclaimed words like white power and white pride for
the sake of good things.
Like cause there's things you can be proud of,
you white about.
And it got,
and it became something that wasn't about neonazis are swastikas.
That it would change the race discussion in this country.
That if white people could sit around and go,
I'm proud to be white without us going,
oh,
something bad's about this.
No one would able to be able to do that because if you even say that at all,
you can pendulum shift.
I'm trying to push it down it,
I don't think that's ever going to fly down.
I have to yell out here on the edges so that in the middle people can go,
okay,
we're not going to do that,
but let's at least talk about racism.
You know what I mean?
You could do it as a sketch and make like a bunch of buffoonish,
cartoonish white people who are calling.
We're proud to be why we love black folks.
I love Tyler Perry,
but says,
Hey,
it's not about loving bite.
It's about living white things.
It's about like,
I love Mumford and sons quite as fun.
Exactly.
Yes.
Too White for me.
That hurts me.
That's what they went so white.
They went back in time.
You'll notice that Mumford and sons,
they're essentially white.
When slavery was legal,
that's what they're doing.
They're drinking out of mason jars.
They all have fucking chapter plantation,
white.
What are you guys doing?
You're wearing vests.
You pretending you're the outlaw Josey Wales.
The fuck are you doing?
But it's very authentic to a version of whiteness.
There's nothing about Mumford and sons.
It feels black.
No,
it's very worth.
It feels,
it feels like,
it feels like white Americana and that's to me it's like man,
it's a new white,
it's a new white that's an old white guys don't mean it's a throwback to the,
it's like,
it's like retro to a time where like,
why are we going back to that time?
Yeah.
There's no black people in those videos.
Are there,
is there black people in Mumford and son videos?
Can you Google that?
It's like black people in a Mumford and sons video.
Could you imagine if they just started with them and find out,
can I be a black guy in your video?
If a bunch of people came to a black movie theater to see a black movie and they
just started playing Mumford and son videos before the movie started and people
would,
white black people just patiently like,
all right,
so let's just,
this is what it is.
Wait for the movie to start it.
Just keep it,
keep it together.
Like thinking of like a movie with Denzel Washington and Morgan Freeman just
loaded up a little basset greatest produced by Oprah Winfrey directly by an
American stars ever in a fucking giant blockbuster like Quintin Tarantino style
movie.
Just gigantic,
huge fucking blockbuster movie based on the story of the civil rights leader.
Everybody gets excited about it.
Places pack with black,
they just played Mumford and sons video after and they troll these people like
they don't get it.
They play like a half an hour of Mumford and sons before the movie and it just
starts the black and then a new one started phase up into a new video.
Oh God.
You should do that for a fucking show,
man.
Do that for sure.
Just troll the people.
Oh yeah,
my God.
That would be incredible.
It's,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a funny thing.
It reminds me,
it was like one time I was watching,
I was flipping the channels and I flip past like the country music channel and I
stopped because it was a music,
it was a video that was playing on the country music channel except there was
black people in it.
And I was like,
yeah.
I was like,
I was like Whoa,
like what's going on here?
Like why there's black people in this country video.
Eric's Rucker too.
That's exactly it.
And I thought that was so funny.
I'm like,
oh since a black guy singing it,
we could black people in this country.
There was a man I was like,
good for you.
Darrius Rucker for uh,
he's tapped into it man.
Cause he tried to release an R and B album and black people went,
no hoodie.
Yeah,
that's the point.
I mean I think he's authentic to himself.
But after Hootie and the blowfish,
he released an R and B album for black people.
Are you show us Jamie?
I'm,
for instance,
there's a bright light.
Oh,
oh
that doesn't count.
It is from the movie Mandela.
Black James Bond doesn't count as an average black person.
Get that fucking shit off our screen.
Although I like good looking guy.
He's a great actor.
He is and all that.
But she,
how dare you,
how dare you say,
well how about a big movie that he's playing and he's playing a fucking guy.
He's like a serial killer and uh,
he goes after a black woman,
like he knocks on the door in the middle of the night,
tells her that his car broke down at an awkward time to release that movie.
Oculus.
Yeah.
I don't,
yeah,
that's why I'm not trying to be an actor.
Not a star in a movie where like he gets the girl.
No,
no,
no cause black guys got it.
We always got it.
We always got to do,
we always got to go a different way,
you know,
cause if anybody should be playing a black superhero should be that dude.
But no.
How about the serial killer first Denzel Washington got to play.
He's the closest to that.
That guy,
he got to play like real superstar type roles that like you would maybe see like
someone else like George Clooney or Brad Pitt or even he sort of never heat.
There's this,
he doesn't do like romantic comedies.
He,
he,
he's clearly doing it bay specific for,
he's very hemmed into the thing whether he's demonstrates choosing it,
but he's not doing like you don't see him in like a full on broad comedy.
You don't see him doing like George Clooney though.
You don't,
but yeah,
but George Clooney always gets the girl and Denzel Washington is in these movies
where like he was in the Pelican brief and it's one of those movies where he
shot him and Julia Roberts did ended up together.
Bang.
And they don't,
they don't,
which is like,
and I don't know whose decision that is,
but it's like George Clooney,
no matter what movie did,
it ends up at the end with him kissing the girl and then the credits rolling.
That's true.
Whereas dental,
it's like there's always a reason.
He's always a,
not that it doesn't always work out for him.
We used to get them killed.
Again,
has disciplined and he can keep the pussy away.
Very disciplined martial artist or something.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a trend going on now though to sort of avoid,
wouldn't sound.
What about him?
He sent a bunch of movies where he gets to do that cause he's this post he's
posted in Zell.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the,
that's the thing he gets to do the things that Denzel either doesn't want to do
or can't do because it feels like he can't,
he does romantic comedies too though.
He did like hitch.
Yeah.
That's via,
he gets to do Intel is the guy who still holding the Sidney Poitier baton.
You might want this and everyone's like,
Nah,
we're good.
Yeah.
He's 100% serious and legit.
Even though he's funny.
I mean he's very funny and movies,
but he's not,
he just this clearly a thing that he's walking a path that I don't want to be
caught up in a thing where he still holding the baton of blackness in a way that
people after him don't have to hold it.
What I was talking about was not going to do movie where he or you played the
guy who beats up the black women.
Like you know,
like he,
he's not,
he's not gonna do that movie unless that dude get some murder gangster and yes.
And he always,
he,
that guy ends up at the end.
If you notice whenever he does the movie about the guy who was in,
it was like a villain.
He gets killed or he ends up at the end broken.
He never does a thing where that guy goes out on top or like,
like training days,
a great movie until I think I got to die.
You know,
like he always gets a come up and sit at the end.
It's a very,
it's a very moral thing he's doing because he wants to show this is not how you
live your life.
Do you think it was a conscious decision on his part?
He chooses those roles.
He's a a list,
you know,
he's,
he is the alias black actor and he's an a list actor,
you know,
I mean,
how many alias black doctors,
others even 10.
No,
there's him.
There's will Smith and then it's a huge dress off
trying.
Yeah,
he's,
he's still working.
I mean,
he's in the,
he's a list in the UK.
He's got a list here.
He's on his way.
He could be,
he's a list.
Yeah,
he's a British actor.
He's a big star over there.
So he speaks with a British accent.
Absolutely.
That's always weird.
Like the guy from the walking dead.
Have you ever heard the director guy from the walking dead?
The,
the,
the Rick ever heard him talking real life and speaks with a total English
accent?
Yeah.
Same as the guy from homeland.
The red headed dude from homeland deep English acts.
You know what I think is weird as Christian Bale,
who's British when he was doing interviews for Batman spoken in an American
accent.
Yeah.
He,
cause he wanted people to accept Batman is bad.
He didn't want to throw them off with a pretty sexist,
fake accents.
We need specifically when he did interviews for the movie Batman,
he couldn't an American,
he's uncle Tom and for a man cause don't seem to have worked out.
Yes.
Yeah.
No,
you make three.
Those three,
three of the biggest action was of all time.
You know who Jackman too?
Who?
Jack Man.
Yeah.
It's Kinda done it too.
He had been in that.
Yeah.
He sort of dumped,
he brings it down a little bit when he's never hear that Australian accent from
him.
Yeah,
he's an odd duck.
He's,
he's got a weird situation going on and he's married to a hundred year old lady
that's going on there.
Dude,
somebody got to want to marry a hundred year old lady.
I am.
Maybe I should have married.
Nobody's got there.
Everybody makes their agreements and once the door closes all up to whatever the
agreement is.
I like [inaudible].
I know what you were saying.
We could just leave it right here.
Yeah,
I'll need to get crazy.
You need to know,
need to accuse anybody of anything or say that something's happened that we
don't know about personally.
We know,
man.
I don't know.
Shit.
You know,
and certainly there's a people,
marriage is in agreement.
Handsome man though.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Beautiful Body.
I never liked him as wolverine,
but that's my own ways.
Too Tall.
You're too tall to be built.
Like Hector Lombard supposed to be this.
I feel like it was supposed to be supposed to be like a young Robert De Niro.
Not even a Robertson.
Yeah,
but definitely too good looking,
but it should be like this wide thick tank of a man.
Like a wolverine.
The animal was a small animal.
That's crazy wild and no one wants to fuck with it.
Covered in hair.
Yeah.
It's not to,
yeah,
it's not supposed to be as beautiful.
Six foot four.
He's a little man.
Perfect abs.
The real wolverine was like five,
six or something like that.
Just this tank of a little short guy with metal bones and killed a lot of people
was a fucking murderer.
Yeah.
That's funny how that's those claws in the movies don't ever like I do.
The damage that you would think you got claws coming out of your hands,
man.
It seems like it'd be show it,
you know,
I mean,
if they could do an r rated version of wolverine where he's just slicing pizza,
like they're starting to get the idea that they can make complex boot,
like they're doing a Deadpool movie,
you know,
Deadpool,
like they're doing it.
I feel like they're leaning into like,
oh no,
that actually adults want to see superhero movies.
But with actual adult things happening.
Well,
the watchmen,
yeah.
But even a more,
Yeah.
Just,
yeah,
more of that.
Cause I,
cause I'm at this point,
I'm a comic book Geek,
at least I was,
and I'd like superhero movies,
but I'm over them.
I just like isn't explosions.
And then you do the CGI and then you do.
And the thing,
I'm a comic book Geek too,
I would definitely was when I was a kid,
I was a huge comic book Geek.
I skipped all the comic movies this summer.
I was just like,
I just couldn't,
I just,
I the Spiderman movie with Andrew Garfield,
the first one.
Yeah.
This is the second one came.
I was like,
no.
And then captain America,
I never,
I'd maybe it's not in my DNA to give a shit about a guy named Captain America.
That's just too much.
It's just too much.
Like come on everybody and he doesn't have any cool powers.
I was so I scored a skip those and kind of got sent cool steroids jars.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's like,
he's super steroids or even more so.
Yeah.
But yeah,
there's a,
there's a difference between a guy like him and say like a guy like the hulk.
Yeah.
I can get behind the hall.
I can get behind.
That's the same thing as my favorite of all time.
That's me.
I'm a,
I was a kid.
I remember the hulk TV shows like the new hawk.
The thing about the Hawk now as they can make it look real,
like the CGI is so good.
And what's his name?
What the fuck is the new dudes name?
Oh,
uh,
the,
the guy who plays a really good actor fucking,
uh,
it's,
I need that pill mark.
The mark ruffled up there goes.
Yeah.
He's a really good at and he's a great,
it was good too.
Yeah,
I had known it would have been good.
I just think the CGI was not up to snuff with Panasonic TV.
Yeah,
Eric.
I think.
Yeah,
that was a good bridge.
Players,
not six foot four,
220 pounds.
Looking at people like,
don't make me turn that off.
You're already the hall already.
Huge
anger issues.
He's great and chopper.
But I just think that that,
that movie that he was in was not a good hulk.
And we'll hang Lee and I think he's a great director.
Admitted he had,
didn't know who the hulk was when he took the movie.
Oh,
that's right.
They basically gave it to him.
It's like you're a big Hollywood director.
Do you want to do this soup,
this superhero movie?
And he said,
so he didn't,
there was no sense that he actually understood or cared,
really love the source material.
Man.
Listen,
sacrilege.
I still feel like,
just let Lou Ferrigno do it every time.
But that's me.
I'm old school.
Be The hulk too.
Fucking small.
But when you saw lord of the rings,
fucking Gandalf is not really that tall in real life.
They get,
they can do stuff I gas but just doesn't look like well I just,
I just think I would rather a person was doing it because I just think it would
be better cause then it's a person,
it's not CGI.
I don't mind the Hawk being CGI because there's no real hulk like w were CGI
looks weird is when it's a CGI version of a real thing.
Like especially animals.
They're not good at that yet.
Like for like even in the game of Thrones,
like you see the dogs,
the wolves,
the dire wolves like that.
It's not really there.
I can kind of pretend it's they're touching the ground and there's something
going on here.
It's not just the worst version was the lions in a I am legend.
Remember that Shit.
It was so goofy.
Like,
oh Christ.
They're the one that I think it was like when the titanic came out and there's a
shot where they,
they sweep over the ship and you see
you don't have any means
whatever to their knees.
Well it's like the opening scene in a video game.
Like when you're getting like,
yeah,
the load screen mark,
the cinematic as a cinematic where it's like,
well this isn't the game but this is,
this makes you think the game was going to be cool.
Yeah,
no,
that's a I'm not,
yeah,
I skipped out on the ones.
Yeah,
they're just not quite there yet.
With Cgi,
we were talking about this the other day with monster movies that like they show
too much.
Like the American Werewolf in London is the perfect example.
You only see that Werewolf like brief seconds.
And so your,
your imagination has to kind of do a lot of work and it's still scary.
But now when you see a monster movie,
you see like minutes and minutes,
that monster monster and it starts to look like a dude in a suit or a CGI thing.
And there's like a CGI thing.
Like the I am legend monsters.
They looked CGI it up.
They didn't look,
they didn't look like the 28 days later zombies who are people that just,
they moved like a real thing that was really in front of you as opposed to these
things that are moving.
Like somebody created on a computer.
Somebody drawn this right now.
Yeah.
But that's just,
you know,
sit at Madec Shit.
Hollywood shit.
Yeah.
What,
what do you think about like Tyler Perry movies?
What do you think about like buffoonish versions of black people has done by
black people?
I have,
I've have talked about Tyler Perry.
The,
I,
I have,
uh,
it's,
my problem with Tyler Perry movies is that there's not enough black filmmakers
out there making movies to not make him look like that's the definitive story of
black people.
And so it's frustrating when people go,
that's it right there.
That's the version of it.
And you go,
if there was other filmmakers,
if,
if spike Lee was still like,
I mean he's a viable filmmaker,
but if there was like,
there was a point in the 90s where black people started directing movies,
he thought,
oh,
we're going to have a lot of major black movie directors.
John Singleton,
Mattie rich slightly predates those people.
And,
but it didn't,
there's not a,
there's still black cinema is still defined by Tyler Perry and Spike Lee Sorta
got out of the house every now and again,
does one of his classic spike Lee movies.
But yeah,
but it's,
my problem is that there's not enough choices so that I have to have the Tyler
Perry discussion because like,
nobody ever goes to you,
like,
you know,
for,
he's going to sit you down and go,
what do you think about a woody Allen movie?
You know what I mean?
Like there's not a ton about woody Allen,
but they're not there.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
I know what I'm saying.
Some VR,
like you're not gonna have to reckon with each and every Hollywood director is,
it reflects on you represented as a white person would be respond to you.
You can go,
like for example,
I can't go,
I don't have an opinion on Tyler Perry movies.
You'd be like,
come on man,
you got it right.
But you can go,
I don't have an opinion on what on,
and you'd be like,
oh,
I guess he doesn't.
He doesn't.
Maybe it doesn't think about it.
You know,
I have to,
as a black person wrecking with Tyler Perry,
I'm glad he's employing people.
He certainly employs more black actresses than anybody else.
And if you're a black actress in Hollywood and your version is getting beat by
Idris Elba and a movie or,
or the the Christian mom who finally meets a man and has a girls club or
whatever the shit is that he's doing.
I have not,
I have not seen any of them,
but I get you go.
I think I'll do the thing where I play the woman who has a,
who's a single mom living in the hood,
trying to get a better opportunity versus Idris Elba going upside your head for
90 minutes.
So you know,
so I so I appreciate that.
I used to be very like,
like fuck Tyler Perry about it,
but I just sort of,
things are complicated man.
You know,
there's a weird scenario two where he does things like old school studio style.
Yeah.
He owns it.
That's the other thing.
There's a part of that word.
The business side is like,
he owns his own studio,
so he literally is making the movies he wants to make and there's,
you know,
there's major Hollywood directors who aren't doing that,
right?
Some,
he writes,
he produces them,
he shoots someone is lot.
He casts them.
He puts himself in them.
My thing now it's just that thing like Ben Affleck's got a new movie coming out
and Tyler Perry is just in it.
Like playing up like a guy.
Really?
Yeah.
Well he does that sometimes and he played well.
There was some or movie word Matthew Fox.
He tried to play it.
He tried to do Alex Crawling and Alex Cross movie.
Nobody's like,
no,
no.
What's Alex Cross is the,
it's the,
it's a series of movies.
Morgan Freeman did,
it was like kissed the girl and yeah,
there's like one of those,
it's based on a series of novels and the caring May and Morgan Freeman played
the character Alex Cross and then he basically redid it and updated it and he
was playing,
the main character is,
I think it's called Alex Cross box was in it.
Yeah.
I didn't know it was based on something.
That's what they're trying to do.
An established property that has been a hit movie.
We're going to Redo it with Tyler Perry and bring his audience in and have a new
franchise.
But nobody bought Tyler Perry as a serious dramatic sort of thriller guy.
Huh?
I mean it would have been better if it was Medea as Alex Cross gone girl is the
new younger.
Yeah.
And Tyler prayer's just in it.
What is it?
What is gone girl Affleck movie.
Yeah.
It's getting a lot of,
it's going to be the new money we are all talking about.
You know,
whether you see it or not,
it's going to be,
what is it about,
I don't know.
Oh it's a kid that's basically his darkness,
kidnapped or something and Tyler praise just in it.
Just as,
I just feel like it's a little bit hard for me to,
how the fuck is,
you have time to do all that shit.
He's got that,
you know,
he's,
I think you can't be that guy without being,
and I say this in the best way possible.
A hustler,
you know,
you can't be,
you can't have gotten to the point that he's at without sort of like making time
to do as many things as you can do.
Cause he's someone who was living out of his car and doing plays and Baptist
churches or something.
And so yeah,
that's where he's to heat the things he did in movies.
Started out his plays that he did in like community centers and pride church
basements.
And he built them up to the thing that you'd go to the Apollo and see a Tyler
Perry play like black theater,
urban black theater.
Does he have a hundred year old wife too,
if you know what I'm saying?
He's got agreements.
I'm sure it's got a great range that's like he's not,
he's not married.
He doesn't have any children taking mom to the movie openings,
homophobic conversation without
being homophobic.
I'm just,
I'm just telling you about the dude.
He takes his mom to the premieres.
I don't have nothing wrong with that.
Whatever he is,
he's,
he's successful at it.
He's like a nice guy.
Yeah.
There's been no scandal,
so we can't be mad at him for any friendly,
it seems friendly,
you know,
get aggressive and angry at people for no reason.
Like the other blacks,
is that what you're saying?
That's what I'm saying.
Oh yeah.
He's one of the,
he's one of the good ones.
He's not like the others.
Jamie and I being one of the good white people,
we like to point out some of the good black people.
Oh,
thank you.
Thank you.
And he's also very articulate.
I don't know if you noticed that.
He speaks so well.
I don't notice color.
Oh,
thanks.
That's one of those people.
Thanks.
That's very helpful.
It's helpful to living in America.
A white person who doesn't see color.
I don't see it.
I just benefit from,
yeah,
I don't see gender.
I don't see notice white privilege because I didn't even notice that I'm
whining.
Awesome.
Just like I don't notice that I'm six foot four all the time.
It just Saturday just,
I just looked down and this seems to be where everything,
I can reach everything.
I don't ever have to stay.
Get a step stool.
Yeah.
I can always see over people at the concerts.
It's great.
I've got a long reach.
If you want a box.
Yeah.
I got,
I got high.
I got high privileged,
but I don't notice it.
Height,
privilege and different things.
I used to be short,
so I had no where.
I can know how short people feel.
Didn't used to be.
You didn't grow.
You weren't black and and grew up into whiteness.
That's true.
That's good point.
Yeah.
That's what,
that's how I feel about,
yeah.
But no,
I was short until I was,
I mean,
whatever the definition of short is till high school.
You started getting tweeted when I was involved in this conversation with a lot
of people about racism and Jon Jones and uh,
you,
you were chiming in about it and uh,
that was a weird conversation.
Not,
not because uh,
the idea that uh,
people being racist against a,
a young fighter.
Like when you see a guy that's doing very well and has a lot of success and then
you see a lot of blow back and people criticizing him,
I always wonder like what is it that they're criticizing?
They're criticizing his personal life,
his behavior.
Like what is he doing that's so terrible.
Yeah.
Like what,
what is it,
how much of that is racism?
And when I said how much of that is racism shit?
Yeah.
I said,
I wonder how much of that is racism.
And then I also said I think he'd be more popular if he was white.
And people like you were saying that we don't like him cause we were like people
made these,
these big jumps in big conclusions.
It's like are you saying that he wouldn't be more popular if he was white?
Cause I think that's ridiculous because there's more white people than there are
black people and white people tend to associate white people.
They want white hero.
We like to see ourselves.
Yes and that's true of all people.
We like to see,
we'd like to see ourselves reflected outside of our,
so I don't even think that's saying that he's not more popular because of
racism.
I think that's like a racial preference thing.
But asking the question,
I wonder if a lot of the blowback,
a lot of the reason why people don't like him,
his racism and I was,
I was a little taken aback.
It was a front page and saw that.
I saw that now and that's why I chimed in because I was like,
I felt like,
oh Joe is experiencing something that I experienced all the time when the in
these discussions and that's why I sort of reached out like I was trying to
reach and go,
hey man,
thank you.
I know what you're doing.
I know what's happening here and I'm a white guy,
so it's hilarious.
Hilarious.
Well,
it's worse because you people acted like you turned trader.
Racism is,
is that people who would not describe themselves as white people felt like you
turned on them because you brought up race or people were saying,
fuck you there.
They were tweeting me like some really mean shit.
I was like,
well,
did you even listen to what I said?
Because people didn't even listen.
They didn't even know they saw it on print somewhere and then it was on the
cover of like a bunch of different news app,
let's say Joe Rogan attributes Jon Jones a lack of success to racism.
Yes.
All I said was that I wonder,
I wonder,
I wonder how much of it is racism a similar thing.
Much smaller happen to me.
Recently I wrote a,
I saw it.
Yeah.
The buzzfeed buzzfeed reached out to me and said,
do you want to write a thing about lack of diversity in late night?
I would been there like you may be over talking about it.
Good.
Not write a thing about it.
I got things to say about it and my thing was,
it's true.
I noticed you can't say it's not white and late night white and male cause they
want to make it white.
I was like,
no,
it's white and male.
Let's be real and but my thing is I'm not worried about late night.
I'm not trying to,
we need to stop focusing on getting a diversity in late night and the rest of us
need to do.
We always do find our own projects and create our own way and stop being the
way,
the way that this is a reaction to late night talk show that you like,
I want to just talk.
I don't want to have to do a skit.
So,
and then the Hollywood reporter said to Debbie,
come out bill.
Their headline was,
it's time for a black host in late night.
Yes,
I saw that.
I was like,
that's not what you said.
How when I say love your tweet to it too,
you said,
Eh,
it's funny when I say,
did you ever notice people here because people here,
everything you know and love is wrong.
And that's the same thing you found out is when you go,
I wonder people here,
you're a racist.
But I thought it was particularly,
it was particularly shocking to me because I'm a white guy
and I'm saying,
I wonder how much of it is racism because are we pretending that racism isn't
real?
It's 300 fucking 50 million people in this country,
right?
If there's 300 plus million people in this country,
what percentage are racist?
If it's 1% let's say it's 1%
we have more than 3 million racists.
Okay.
We know it's more than 1% so what percentage has a hard time dealing with a
dominant male athlete in a combat sport that beats the fuck out of everybody and
is like young and brash.
So has the thing that there been comparisons of John Jones to Ali young only in
this he has the same thing all he had where he's considered to be an outsider to
the sport.
You know that there's a thing with Jon Jones where it's like he came there,
the stuff I've heard about Jon Jones is that he's,
he's unorthodox or he's not,
he didn't come up the way he learned on youtube videos.
There's sort of this,
this,
this legend that has been created about him,
about like that he's not that the sport,
but he's not a guy like,
uh,
I dunno like you think about like a George Saint Pierre George Saint Pierre.
No,
I'm thinking of the black guy.
The guy had Jon Jones,
they were friends and then he'd beat her shot Rashad Evans who sorta was raised
by the sport through the ultimate fighter.
And so people got to see him sort of like,
people got to feel like I saw that guy on the TV show and now,
now he's our champion.
Whereas John Jones sort of came from the outside and very quickly dominated and
that threatens people sometimes
to,
well he actually see,
there's a misconception when it comes to martial arts and one of the big ones is
that wrestling is not a martial art.
John was a very successful wrestler all throughout high school and college and
that is probably the most important martial art.
The ability to dictate where the fight takes place is probably the most
important aspect of fighting.
And John was an outstanding wrestler and the only reason why he didn't go on to
be a college star,
because he got his girlfriend pregnant and had to get a job.
That is why he got,
but he was being actively recruited by a bunch of different universities because
he was a very talented wrestler.
And then on top of that,
he grew up with two fucking giant super athlete brothers.
And he used to Duke it out all the time.
Like John's parents would laugh about how their,
their,
their kids would just wrestle and fight in the living room.
And that is a reality.
If you grew up with big brothers,
you can use to combat in the household on a daily fucking base.
You got to fight for cereal.
Like this fucking dude took your basketball,
someone,
you know,
someone's got your shit,
you got to Duke it out and got a flight to go to the bathroom.
You to,
yeah.
And even if it's not a real fight,
there's competition like high level competition.
So when he came out of nowhere,
he was still a very good athlete and a very good wrestler.
And wrestling is a hugely important martial art.
So it's no more unusual than a guy who's a worldclass kickboxer who enters into
MMA,
starts knocking people out.
That's Kinda,
it's Kinda to be expected.
So I think that's just a mistake.
Yeah.
I'm not saying it,
but it's definitely like he's the,
you're,
you're black,
you're better than everybody and you,
you didn't come up the way we want you to have come up into this sport.
Why don't,
see,
I don't know about that.
That's where we disagree.
Okay.
I mean,
I just,
I feel like that was the thing that I've,
when I first heard about Jon Jones was that there was this,
the myth was created that like,
you know,
he learned from watching youtube videos.
I remember hearing shit like that you didn't learn very quickly,
very quickly and people kind of don't like when,
so this is a thing we tell it like it was like with the young cash with Cassius
Clay,
when somebody is so young and so much better than everybody,
and then you put the black thing on top of that.
He might've got that if he was white and so much better than everybody.
They kind of,
they get,
they sorta getting threatened by that and then you put black on top of it.
It's like that's a recipe for a America.
Yeah.
People.
And then if we can find some faults in your character.
Oh Dude.
Was he drinking and driving history as a,
as a professional athlete or is it especially in a combat sport?
All you,
all the guys are,
this is the,
this is not the polite thing.
Yeah.
You want,
you actually want your fighters to be bad.
Asses who drink and get in fights and do something,
you know,
that's,
that's to me,
the,
to fault him for that is ridiculous.
It's very difficult to find a bad ass that doesn't do that.
Yes.
Yeah.
Like Donald's Serone,
who's one of the best fighters in the UFC,
he,
he's,
he's a real fucking crazy wild man.
His name's cowboys nicknames cowboy.
Where's the fucking cowboy hat?
Everywhere literally was a bull rider and drinks beer up until the day of the
weigh ins.
Okay.
D takes the day off to weigh in and then after the winds will have a beer,
like the day before it's fucking fight.
And in between fights,
he's jet skiing,
wakeboarding,
and he's a wild motherfucker,
but he's a white dude.
So like all this talk about him drinking and he's never like crash a car.
He's not married.
He doesn't have,
there's a,
there's a bunch of shit that John was like involved in that,
that gave people an excuse to be upset enough.
They gave him an excuse because if,
if they liked him,
that stuff would be the things that made him like,
oh,
he's a bad ass.
He doesn't give a shit.
He's out there driving as Bentley and the trees like that.
That would be stuff that he was celebrated for.
If they liked him,
yes,
if they liked him.
But I heard people say like,
oh,
he's so fake.
He's so fake.
Like he's fucking 27 years old.
You don't even know who you were when you were 27 and if you were,
were you the fucking light heavyweight champion of the world?
We would have heard about the amount of pressure and the,
the,
just the scrutiny that he's under.
It's just unprecedented.
Yeah,
and I think that it's a MMA at this point,
I think is a,
I mean I've,
I feel like if that,
if I was,
if I ever made like sort of fuck you money or money to do,
I would open Jujitsu gyms in the ghetto to train the next generation of black
MMA fighters because I feel like there's guys in there who could be,
it remains a very white sport right now.
Now black guys historically have been fighters like it,
professional boxers,
but professional boxing guts,
so corrupt that the strongest,
toughest black gang out in that place for the NFL.
He doesn't,
he's not a boxer.
He's not a heavy heavyweight field though.
I don't think there'll be a black heavyweight champion really ever again.
Really Nice.
You say that just because you know who Deontay Wilders?
No,
no bad motherfucker.
I hope they're being undefeated heavyweight and just smashing people.
Good,
big tall,
long,
lanky dude who's got,
oh,
I think he's all knockouts.
Record is just,
he's a guy that got famous recently because there was some crazy fuck who was on
the Internet who's talking all kinds of crazy shit to him.
And so he met him in a ring and beat the shit out.
You didn't see that.
No,
no.
I got to see that.
Yeah.
Some crazy guy who said some fucked up things about his daughter and beat the
fuck out of him in a,
in a video that was on TMZ and everything.
Well,
I think,
I just think that there's,
the culture of professional boxing in this country has changed in the black
community that I think,
I think people,
I think there's a sense of like if Mike Tyson had vendor Holyfield and ended up
broke,
what chance do I stand?
Floyd Mayweather has untold amounts of money.
It's my time management,
I shit it is for now.
I don't,
and I'm not trying,
I don't want to get a war with Floyd Mayweather started,
but I just feel like who had Mike Tyson had untold amounts of money.
Now,
Mayweather has more because of his airplane mode,
but Mike Tyson,
who Mike Tyson and Holyfield head untold amount of money at the time and they're
both,
I don't think,
I don't know how they're living,
but they're not living the way they were.
But that's a management issue.
It hasn't been.
But I think the problem is is you come in,
it's the same thing we talked about earlier.
You come out of the,
the bad neighborhood,
you,
you don't,
you learn,
they learn.
You're an athlete.
They don't teach you the rest.
They don't teach you like how to be a good manager to that.
You're signing with a,
with a boxing manager,
Don king who just like,
just sign this blank piece of paper.
I'll take care of it.
So it's a,
it's a recurring process that happens and that thing,
whereas at least if you go to the NFL,
you get a contract,
you get an actual thing that we're going to pay you this much and it's not
guaranteed.
Or if you go to the NBA,
you get a guaranteed contract.
Or my theory is that a lot of those dudes go,
instead of going into a boxing ring and get my brains beat,
now I'm just going to hang out with the best basketball player in town and be
his NBN as posse.
You know that it doesn't pay as much,
but at least I'm not getting ripped off.
I don't know where's,
where's the [inaudible] champion?
What?
Why aren't black guys in boxing anymore or the why aren't there?
Why he used to be that it was a done deal that a black guy would be the
heavyweight champion.
There is a real problem and that problem is a six foot six Russian,
Vladimir Klitschko who's one of the best boxers that heavyweight division's ever
known.
I mean,
Vladimir Klitschko is up,
I'm not fucking,
I'm not in any way,
but it's just,
no,
it's weird.
Who would've ever thought that we would be a white heavyweight champion that no
one gives a fuck about?
No one gives a fuck about,
no one gives a fuck about the heavyweight champion.
He used to be the the most famous guy on the planet and that,
and that ended with when Lennox Lewis retired.
I think,
dude,
I was on a fucking plane,
Vladimir Klitschko and no one knew who he was.
I was thinking about whether I should interrupt him and say hi and say I'm a big
fan.
Like that dude's probably so happy that no one's talking to him right now.
I'll leave him alone.
But then I realized no one was talking to him.
Nobody fucking talk to him.
There's a,
that's a a shift.
The heavyweight champion used to be the most famous guy on the plane.
Yeah.
My friend goes,
man,
that guy is fucking huge.
I go,
do you know that's a heavyweight boxing champion,
the world.
He goes,
what?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I got that.
That's Vladimir Klitschko now in Ukraine.
He would be,
I'm sure he gets them up in Germany.
He actually speaks like five different languages.
He's a phd.
He's a brilliant guy.
I mean,
it's a really unique guy to be a heavyweight champion.
Him and his brother were heavyweight champions in the same time.
Didn't want to end.
Didn't fight each other.
It was so strange thing is so corrupt.
I mean there's like,
you know,
why do you say that?
What do you,
what do you,
what,
what do you think is corrupt about it?
I think no Shay statement.
Well here's what the,
here's why the value,
I'll bring it to this.
The UFC is doing a good job right now.
It's a central organization that has a series of practices and this is the way
you have to do it.
And that,
that,
that the,
you can call it a monopoly if you want to,
but it's a centralized organization that runs everything.
Boxing is a bunch of different organizations that each set their own rules and
don't.
So there's not a way to go.
How do we make these fighters fight?
You can't avoid a fight if you're the best guy in the UFC and there's a number
two guy,
you guys are going to fight.
No.
But boxing,
cause there's a bunch of splinter organizations,
you can't,
we never got to see Holyfield Tyson fight in their prime,
you know,
because of Pacquiao and Mayweather because of all the,
all the back water deal.
People are trying to keep the,
protect their side of it.
And so I don't want him to fight that guy because if he loses then we lose all
our things.
So there's,
it's not what's good for the sport.
It's what's good for the bottom line and the dollar and what the,
and so therefore it leads to corruption and it leads select things that happened
where,
why aren't these fights happening?
And then,
and also the thing with Don King,
you know,
he Tyson will tell,
I'm sure you to,
I talked to my Tyson before then don king became the biggest promoter because he
was ripping everybody the fuck off.
And so there's no central authority to rule over and say,
we have to clean this up so and so and so.
It leads to a lot of corruption.
And it leads to,
there's no reason that Mike Tyson should be broke right now.
Despite all the shit he went through.
There's no reason.
That's where I disagree with you.
I don't attribute that to to corruption and neither does he.
He just went crazy and spent all his money.
I mean he has a fucking one man Broadway show where he talks about shows 350
million.
He goes,
yes,
I spent that much,
but he's he,
he did spend that much,
but he also,
I'm sure would tell you,
and that somebody also too,
that somebody else took millions of dollars from him that they weren't supposed
to have.
They okay.
That is true.
Someone stole money from him.
However,
if he had that money,
he would spend it too.
Well I would,
I wish I would.
I would like to give him the chance to spend it.
That's all I would have liked to have been with someone who is a financial
advisor who would have set some money aside very early on.
And you know as [inaudible] has that.
Yes he does.
Yeah.
We were talking about that recently and Iverson turns 50 he gets millions of
dollars,
millions of dollars.
So he's just,
he's just working for the,
I think for the 70 sixers until that kicks in.
And I think that that the Michael Jordan sort of established the modern NBA of
like,
no,
get a money manager and get a guy who protects your things and don't invest in
stupid shit.
And so some people will end up broke,
but you think that the NFL is corrupt.
Do you think that the NBA is corrupt?
Not In the way that boxing is curled because this way cause a you 80% of NFL
players within two years or bankrupt after they retire.
80% yes.
60 something percent of NBA player.
Same thing.
Bankrupt within two years of retirement.
So I don't think it's an issue of corruption when it comes to how much money
they blow,
as much as they get that money,
it's flowing in like a river.
The ESPN documentary broke.
Yeah,
I didn't say it.
It's about,
it's about,
it's about that.
Yeah.
Guy like Mike Tyson was,
grew up in Brownsville,
poor as hell.
And then all of a sudden he has hundreds of millions of dollars.
He's got,
Tiger's Charlie Murphy came on my podcast until the fucking story about Mike
Tyson about showing up at Mike Tyson,
Mike Tyson in the front lawn plane with a tiger.
So he had a fucking tight,
nobody would get out of the car.
Everybody stayed in their car.
Here's my thing,
the corruption leads to people not wanting to participate in the sport in the
same way.
That's what I believe.
I don't think so man.
I just think that the,
that you go,
why don't I have used to be a football player looking at it in terms of this
longterm thing.
I think there's less people that are getting involved in boxing first of all,
because more people are getting involved in MMA.
That's one thing that's definitely happening,
but black more black dudes aren't getting involved.
I mean maybe starting to,
but that wasn't the,
there was a,
uh,
there was a disk,
there was a,
a gulf between the end of boxing being a big sport then of heavyweight champions
being a big thing and in the MMA taking prominence and that,
what was it,
what happened in that Gulf?
Like between Lennox Lewis going,
I'm out in between and to John Jones there's like a Gulf of like where did all
the black,
white,
old black heavyweight champions go.
Where'd all the black dudes who are going to be here?
But there was still a lot of black fighters in the lower weight classes.
Like that was Roy Jones was still around.
There's Hopkins,
if you're thinking about
the heavyweight champion was the baddest motherfucker on the planet.
It's hard to find really big dudes that are willing to get punched in the face.
Yeah,
that's your thing is boxing is just so fucking hard to do in comparison to other
sports like football because not that football's not hard to do,
but you,
you could be a great football player and never have the courage to be able to
step into a ring on your own and your underwear and go toe to toe with a gun.
Cause you could,
you know,
Bob could fucking drop the ball and you can lose the game and you can still go
out and party.
But if you get your ass kicked,
you got your fucking ass kid.
You did it,
it's all on you.
Yeah.
A lot of people are not psychologically bill for that.
We'll that.
But that's the thing I think is interesting.
For years they were up through up through a Holyfield and Tyson.
They were,
and then some what,
and again,
some of those dudes are getting concussions in the NFL,
like,
you know?
Yes.
It's not like,
I just think there's,
you know,
that's my theory about it.
I certainly don't you right.
But I just feel like this,
the culture of the sport became so corrupt that I don't think people,
I see where you're coming from,
but I really honestly don't think that it's coming from a point of like,
okay,
we've seen the future.
This is where this ends up.
Let's not do this.
No,
I don't.
And that's why the future.
But I think there's a sense that like if you're a kid,
if you're a kid who's six foot three,
two 50 and you go,
man,
do I want to be a,
do I want to be a basketball player like Lebron James or Michael Jordan or Kobe,
right.
We're going to be a boxer,
like a Vanderhoof fit or my,
Oh wait a second it dudes are broke.
Do you know what I mean?
But they didn't have to be broke man.
They did.
They are.
They are the nuts and more importantly than broke his brain damage.
I think that is the most intelligent thing to avoid.
Yes.
I think that as one thing,
as different economic groups,
uh,
excel in the culture,
they become less likely to be fighters.
That is one thing that happens on a pretty,
pretty consistent basis.
Whoever on the bottom of the economic it.
That's why it was Irish dudes.
Yeah.
And I think it's Italian for awhile.
It's also boxing.
It's like brain damage.
Fucking unavoidable.
Yes.
And you can't,
you can't do it for long without,
I mean I think Lennox Lewis got out when he was like,
okay,
I've beaten everybody at this point.
It's just going to be about taking too many hits to the head.
Yeah.
And very smart.
And he's shown a little bit of deterioration now.
How could you not you can't you,
how could you not?
Nobody rides for free.
That was a big boxing fan.
So I just,
I sort of missed the fact that the heavyweight title was like an event,
like wouldn't use like this.
It wasn't then you,
everybody paid attention.
People who didn't care about boxing knew who the heavy weight champion goes are
boring as fuck.
Boring because they're smart and they're not,
they're not going in there to,
they're not trying to have blood wars.
Like,
you know,
when you watch seven,
1970s boxing and it's like,
you know,
15 rounds Ernie Shavers.
Yeah.
And it's a dude be like breaks his jaw and the third round and it says,
I'm good.
No,
I didn't break my jaw.
I didn't break my job.
Yeah.
Like it's like,
you know,
I'm a huge Ali fan.
He's another surrogate Dolly,
Ken Norton because John and they just still,
nope,
don't say,
don't tell him buddy.
I'll see you at the hospital later that I missed that spectacle of like,
I mean,
I remember being in a video store in Chicago and they had the Tyson fight on and
it was like,
maybe it was a Carl the truth.
Yeah.
And it was like the thing where me and my friend go,
oh,
let's just stay a minute.
This will only take a minute.
And it did.
Like I liked that,
you know?
And so you know that I'm a fan of that and I miss it.
And I don't think all those dudes ended up in MMA yet.
I mean,
maybe they will.
I think most of them ended up in football and a lot of them ended up in
basketball.
Terry Norris Turney Norris was a one of those guys from that day.
It was a big star.
He's all fucked up now,
man.
I ran into him in Vegas a few years back and I was listening to him talk to some
fans and he was slurring his words and could barely put a sentence together.
And I was like,
Damn.
I remember when Terry Norris was the champ.
Yeah.
And it's weird to think about Ali,
for example,
it's the jury's out whether he got his Parkinson's related to the center right
now.
Fuck that jury.
The jury's it filled with idiots.
Yeah.
Tell you from a person as a lifetime investment in combat sports.
That's 100% trauma related.
Okay.
Yeah.
Parkinson's is a trauma related disease and a lot of people,
Freddy Roach has Parkinson's related trauma.
Okay.
It's one of the reasons why he forced Manny Pacquiao to take a whole year off
after mark has knocked him out.
He's like,
dude,
you're not fighting now we're going to take a year off.
Yeah,
just to get yourself.
Well that's a great,
well then the Ali who's still alive,
we sort of almost treat him like he's dead.
And then every now and again,
like he just joined Twitter and you're like,
it's just weird to be like,
and some of them were coming from the champion you like,
are they really like if Ali was still with you because he's not that old.
He's in his 70 [inaudible] he's old,
but he's not like,
you know,
he's got a hundred if he was still around and still talking as in
talking relatively fast and was,
he was,
he'd be an ambassador for you should be a boxer.
But because of,
like you said,
the trauma related injuries,
he has not,
there's no,
no old boxers.
A good ambassador for boxing except Bernard Hopkins,
which is ridiculous.
49 years old still.
The champ talks great.
Still full of energy outboxes and shit out us and young guys.
He's a freak man.
I think we just talked about earlier with the,
some people are doing crystal meth and it's fine.
It's the same thing that everybody has to take the hits.
Well he's also got a very intelligent style.
He doesn't brawl with anybody.
He brawls on his terms clinches a lot.
He holds onto guys.
He,
he'll,
he'll use rough house tactics to push them out of their game and just aware he
understands what to do.
Like before boxing is one of those things where if you look at it and on like if
you don't have any education in,
in boxing and you watch it on television like,
well this guy is trying to hit this guy and the other guy is faster so he can't
hit him.
No.
This footwork involved.
There's,
he's doing movements that get you to react and he's anticipating your reaction
and then giving you another thing to think about.
And then when you react to that,
you're going to step here and he's ready with an overhand right.
And these things are all in his mind.
These are all foregone conclusions.
But to a young guy,
he's just going to use his speed and his death,
but you don't ever get a chance to use that speed.
He's already on you.
He's already making you move and dance to his rhythm.
He's got your,
he's the Marionette,
you're the puppet and you don't realize it until it's the 10th round.
You get your ass kicked and you're like,
fuck.
And they're like,
you need to knock guy.
Like I can't even fucking,
you know,
I can't,
I haven't touched him since the first round.
You see that Russian guy that he beat for the light heavyweight title,
he's boxing the shit out of the sky.
And the 10th round Blam dropped some.
They're like,
you know,
you need to stop him unions in the 10th round Hopkins drops him.
Mother fucker can't even hit him.
No,
it's just too good.
I,
in college I briefly joined a boxing club and got hit by a dude who was not a
professional boxer,
but like the hardest I've ever had been hit in my life and I was like,
Oh,
I think I'm done with this boxing club.
Like,
you know,
you get rocked hard.
I was like,
I think I'm going to just go back to class.
They will trying to be a comedian,
but boxing to be taught properly should be taught where you don't hit each other
hard at all.
Well this was,
Alicia was like a guy who had like an x as in Philadelphia at this guy was an ex
boxer,
had fought sugar ray Leonard.
Like that was his big story.
It lost the sugary lender,
which is numbers.
Name.
Uh,
no,
this was a long time ago.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't remember his name,
but he was a,
I would recommend he,
yeah,
he fought sugar ray Leonard in Philly at the blue horizon.
A lost man.
Lost a fight.
But that was her eyes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like he played the video for us,
but you know,
he just sort of put,
it was a block boxing club.
We just to put us in a room and there was no ring.
It was just like,
and there was one guy,
five all the fare the same height.
So,
but that guy,
he outweighed me.
I was like six four,
one 90 he was like six four,
you know,
to 60 or something.
And it's like,
I don't think we're asking the same way class.
And he was the guy who was and he rocked me and it was just that thing and I'd
head gear on.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
that's is,
this is not a,
I think I'm a be these words.
Yeah,
you could learn how to box,
but you got to learn how to box today,
especially in today's Day and age.
You got to learn how to do it from someone who respect brain trauma and
understands like the goal is not to just go in there and beat the shit out of
each other and the strong person survives.
The goal is to teach someone how to move their head.
So they don't get hit when he's got his right hand there.
That means the punch is coming this way.
I want you to duck under it and then you counter and do everything nice and slow
at first.
Develop the movements and then when you spar spar in a very controlled way and
you'll actually get better at it and then you know you could actually become a
real boxer.
But the problem is a lot of these gyms,
they don't,
they don't want pussies.
I just take you and throw you in there.
Yeah,
it put lace them up.
Yeah.
Although now there's cardio boxing where they are,
which is not exactly what you're talking about,
where it's like we're just pretending to buck hitting bags mostly and they're
doing it with poor form.
I went to a cardio boxing class and I was watching these people hit the bag of
Mcdonald's,
even telling them to do it right,
like everything they're doing,
they're all fucking whale in their arms,
all goofy and they're not throwing their hips,
lifting their feet up when they punch and no one's correcting him.
I'm like,
this is not boxing.
This is just hitting shit.
It ain't shit is exercise.
You know,
can't even call it cardio boxing.
Um,
but it,
it is interesting what you said about the,
the heavyweight division,
the heavyweight division being this division that's sort of,
but you still have guys like Adrian Broner that are coming up.
You'd still have guide.
I have not paid attention a long time because it sort of became a thing where it
just,
it was just felt like a desert,
but it's just a heavyweight division.
Yeah.
No,
no.
I will,
I will watch many packages.
Fucking Russians have a stranglehold on that mother fucker.
Yeah.
They're not letting it go.
It'll be interesting to see,
cause he's still the champ,
right?
Klitschko Oh yeah.
When he,
cause he's pretty old too.
He's not a young dude.
He was like 40.
Yeah.
But when he retires,
like what happens?
Like what,
you know,
I think that boxing could use a central organization that sort of like,
it's never going to happen.
No,
no.
And I think that's,
you know why?
Because you can start your own organization.
The ghetto.
That's what I'm going to start to.
MMA has done it in a way where like if you organized a,
an event,
like you call it the WTF,
oh,
whatever the fuck it is,
and you decided to have an event and you say,
this is my w fo world champion.
That's a world champion.
That's what the WBA does for boxing.
The IBF,
the Ibo,
there's all these different organizations.
WBC,
UFC.
Is that the thing?
It's like the NFL super bowl champion is a fucking NFL champion.
Yeah.
There's no question that the,
whoever wins the super bowl is the best football team in the world at that
point.
There's not somebody in,
there's not a football team in Europe.
It's like,
no,
we could actually,
exactly.
Yeah.
And the problem is with boxing is there's just so many organizations and once
that happens you can't take it back.
No,
you can't get all those people together and say,
hey,
let's all form one organization and we'll split the money but the fuck out of
you.
And that's the,
again,
it's the everybody wants the money is what dictates the thing.
So they,
I mean,
I remember when unifying the title was three
titles.
Yup.
It was the WBA,
the WBC and IBF.
IBF was late in the game around like the eighties I believe.
Yeah.
I remember when people resist both.
I think he threw it in the trash.
Get through one of the titles of the Trashcan and yeah,
big deal.
Yeah.
Ridiculous.
Sanctioning fees.
The sanction fees to fight for a WPA test fucking through the roof.
It's crazy money.
Like for what are you,
what are you fucking,
what am I getting that given you $1 million and what the fuck are you getting?
This is again,
it's the,
that's the,
I mean maybe some wouldn't call it corruption,
but I think that's the corruption is everywhere.
Trying to get as much of the money as they can,
but it's not good for the sport.
You know what it should be,
man,
it should be like ring magazine.
Yes.
You know,
ring magazine has a rank champion.
I don't think they have to pay to be the ring champion.
I should abandon everything.
But the ring title,
ring magazine is not going to do your dirty.
They,
they're there.
They want the sport to be good,
they want the best.
And I think that that's the problem with the edit.
There's my in it.
Yeah.
There's money in deciding who's the WBC,
the WBA.
It's that unchecked capitalism thing.
Communism as a point.
Yeah.
I enjoy this phone that was made by Chinese children,
but I also think that we should probably pay them a living wage.
You know,
you gotta make good phones,
but let's pay them a living wage.
Whenever you have nets around the building where you work to keep people from
jumping off the roof,
cause there's so many fucking people jumping off that you'd need nets.
Yes.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe we should think we should look into this.
Yeah.
Maybe we should.
Do you,
um,
do you think there's a way around that?
Because that's,
that's drives me nuts about not just cell phones,
but about like people that drive Prius's and Shit and say that I'm helping the
environment,
I'm being socially conscious.
And you're also driving a fucking box filled with conflict minerals.
Yeah,
every fucking lithium ion crystal and that came out of a fucking mine in the
ground in Africa and it's likely a child that might have been pulling it out.
You know,
somebody said to me that day because of my act in the way I talk about things
like how would you identify yourself?
You were socialist and your comment is like not do that.
He's went to the apple store and got me an iPod touch.
I'm a very,
I'm a very proud,
maybe a reluctant capitalist,
but I also like a nice house too.
I just,
I just think that there's ethics,
there's ethics rules.
Like if I'm like when I go to pay,
when I went to go try to buy a new phone and they said it's going to be $700 if
I,
if I thought that that's $700 was actually going to a living wage for somebody,
maybe,
I don't know if I buy it,
but I would think about it,
but I know it's like you're just making up a price.
Yeah.
This is not actually a pot,
like we're probably paying too little for our phones.
They should probably all be twice as much as they are,
but we all had this thing where I want the 50 isn't it $50 with the free rebate
or something?
Right.
We want that,
but that's a problem because that doesn't,
that doesn't help the world.
It's the same thing with like with like,
uh,
the minimum wage,
raising the minimum wage.
If you raise the minimum wage,
you have less job turnover.
If people have more pride in their job,
because we have customer services sucks in this country because the dude got
hired two days ago and he's looking and he's looking a new job isn't there also
like when you look at the amount of profit that apple has made and probably the
apple has something like $60 billion in the fucking bank,
like how much would you have in the bank if you paid people more money to make
those phones and you made them in America and you made less profit,
but the people all made a living wage like can we worked out on paper?
That's so I can see what that would be.
Well,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing with Walmart.
Like they,
they,
if they paid everybody like $12 an hour,
they would,
they would make like $3 billion.
Like it's still,
yeah.
It's not like how much profit do you need to make and at some point,
and I get that you're allowed to set the price,
whatever you want.
I feel like I'm some market,
I'm talking to my dad right now.
Yeah.
Like my dad has a bargain,
but we all have to agree.
We live in a society that we're not individuals living in our little islands,
but I think corporations treat it like I am.
We are all our own little country.
Well,
there's a reason why there's something like a minimum wage and that we all kind
of agree there should be some minimum wage is because corporations have no
fucking soul.
No.
It just about money.
They're about bottom line in there.
In fact,
their duty to their shareholders is to increase their bottom line and they have
to make more every year.
Yes.
Yeah.
They can't.
They can't have flat,
they can't have flat growth.
They have to Harris,
we made $1 billion last year.
We only made $1 billion this year.
What's happening down there?
What's happened to those kids in that factory?
Yeah,
they need to make less.
And so the,
the thing that I think is like,
and the thing with the minimum wage is that it hasn't kept up with inflation.
If minimum wage is tracked with the ICAN with inflation and the,
it would be fine,
but it has not kept up.
And so,
and you know my dad who I've talked to my dad,
but it was like,
well that's,
those jobs are pass through jobs.
You're not supposed to have work at Walmart forever.
Hey,
the factory left town.
Yeah.
There's no good union jobs and there's not a lot of good union jobs where you
can work at the GM factory for 25 years and retire with a gold watch.
Yeah.
Walmart is the factor.
I feel like there's some jobs that are really good for kids.
There's some jobs and kids just get out of high school and they have an entry
level job there.
There are some jobs that probably shouldn't pay a shitload of money,
but no,
not a shitload,
but they should.
Yeah.
If you're working all week,
you should be able to live on that.
Yes.
If you fulltime work,
you should be able to afford to,
he should be able to eat and you should be able to sleep somewhere and the,
and the government should want you to be able to be able to actually not just
live for yourself,
but also be married and have an afford to be married and afford to have a kid
having two kids because that all feeds the economy.
Like you shouldn't want somebody to be struggling and not afford to.
I guess we can to have a kid and I guess or whatever.
We can only have one cause I guess you need a better job come out.
She need to get out of North Dakota somehow and find yourself a good place where
you can get a good income.
Exactly.
I moved to San Francisco.
You can't afford to live.
Yeah.
We didn't get a $4 million shack.
So I did that.
It's such a,
it's to me that's so clear that like,
no,
if we raise the minimum wage it helps the economy certainly sends her.
But I have a small business and if I raised them in which your employees won't
be so shitty,
that's what will happen and they won't quit every two weeks.
How much money should it be though?
What should the minimum wage be?
I think I,
I,
I mean I'm not an economist,
but I think $15 an hour is not outside the bounds of no reasonable.
For somebody who's like,
and I think I don't even have a problem if you track it to the city.
Like I think some cities you need $17 an hour.
In some cities maybe you need 12 right.
You know,
I think that's just the,
the,
the way,
cause like San Francisco,
San Francisco has a higher minimum wage then the Nash than the national minimum
wage.
Does it?
Yes.
It's like,
I forget,
I don't know what the national mood,
but San Francisco is like bucks or something.
It's like eight 50 I think because they know that it's still,
it's fucking San Francisco,
you know,
it's,
they,
they are aware and it's still present.
It's still not enough,
but at least there's the service about,
we realized that this is the,
the city is not North Dakota.
There's three things that you bring up when people go fucking bananas about
climate change,
racism and minimum wage.
And we've talked about all three of them.
All right?
When you start talking about minimum wage,
the fucking quote unquote economic experts,
by the way,
here's what I've noticed.
Most of them aren't rich.
One of the people,
the people that fucking chime in on these discussions.
I've had deep conversations with these people like back and forth for a long
time,
but I know zero about economics.
And so when I've said,
hey,
I just think that people should be able to live on the amount of money that they
make during the week,
and people come up with all these reasons why that's bullshit and all these
reasons why that's bad for business and all these years.
And I eventually,
in the conversation I get to how much do you make?
What do you do?
Are you,
do you run a business or you know,
none of them run buck and businesses.
They all have this idea in their head that America is filled with people.
And I've,
I've read this quote somewhere,
I forget who to,
who to attribute it to that think that they are about to become a millionaire
and they want to make sure there's no laws in place.
They're going to fuck them over once they become a millionaire.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's the,
it's people.
It's the reason why people vote against their own personal interest because I'm
going to vote with the,
then I'm not trying to,
but I'm going to vote with the Republican party because they have,
they don't want taxes.
And one day I'm going to be rich and I'm not going to what?
Taxes.
Even though it's like,
well right now you're getting you some taxes might help you.
You know what I mean?
Like it would help you.
It would help your community and your neighborhood.
But no,
I'm one day.
So we're just thinking the world is a people that are republican that are broke,
that are voting for corporate interests.
Yes.
It's like what are you doing?
Cause people think that everybody thinks they're one.
Not Everybody.
A lot of people think they're one lottery ticket away from being in the 1% or
one step or one or one.
One jump shot one.
Yeah.
So,
but it's weird how the Republican Party is like a party that supports big
business,
like sort of unequivocably.
Yet they're more supported by under in colic,
lower income conservative people.
It's the reason why people who don't live in New York like the Yankees,
because they feel like they're the best.
They're,
they're the,
they're the winning team.
And even though it's not connected to,
even though it's not connected to them,
they just feel like I want to be with the winners.
Also,
the team that is most aligned with Jesus is the Yankees wasn't publicans.
Oh,
Republicans,
yes.
No.
Well,
Republicans,
by tying
patriotism to God that's swept the whole bunch of people in there.
I saw a sign in Alabama that said America,
bless God,
I don't even know what that means,
but that was a billboard that I saw that was sort of,
so we're like,
wait,
we're,
yes,
we got was America.
But it was actually like putting,
it was sort of saying,
no,
we made as the god of Americans to God and,
and I was like,
I'm not sure what that means,
but clearly I don't think I want to rent a house here.
America is better than the creator of the universe.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You believe in the creator of the universe.
America's better than that.
So we bless the creator of the universe,
keeps a little pat on the head.
God,
good job making that she didn't take it from here.
Yeah.
I see a new American US Logan,
we'll take it from here.
America blessed.
Oh,
there it is.
Eh bless God.
I need you at my house.
Look at that fucking billboard.
Meanwhile,
it's a conti flying lizard.
If you ever met her lizard,
I mean a,
an eagle.
No.
You ever seen an eagle?
I saw one last summer for the first time in real life.
And you look into the eyes of that heartless monster.
You're like,
well how the fuck is this?
Our National Bird?
Yeah,
our national and crazy.
A little bit.
Or there dinosaurs,
dinosaurs that survived.
If you,
if you pulled away all the feathers,
and by the way,
uh,
they think that most dinosaurs had feathers.
Now they're starting to reconsider the idea of dinosaurs and feathers.
I do think a lot of dinosaurs had feathers,
so they essentially are fucking dinosaurs.
So that gives Steven Spielberg way to rerelease all the Jurassic Park movies
now,
which feathers,
you don't know what the fuck was on those things.
They don't know what color they were.
They know they had some sort of skin,
but all they have is bones.
And that's speculation,
but in more,
and we like,
we like to think our lizards are green,
so we just make it.
Yeah.
Well they also think that at t rex might've been like vulture shaped or vulture
colored,
like bright red faced and black body because they think that he might've been
like intimidating because they think he was more of a,
they think it was more of instead of a Predator,
he was more of a carrion eater.
He was,
he probably stole away from somebody else who killed it because his body's all
fucked up the way it doesn't have.
The arms can't really run that good.
They,
and they also speculate about the earth's atmosphere being different than,
that's one of the reasons why things grew so big.
It was a more oxygen rich and dense atmosphere,
but they think that there's a lot of dinosaurs had feathers,
so a fucking eagle is a dinosaur.
So when you're looking at that thing with a bolt cutter for a face,
like how was this heartless evil baby steel and flying monster,
that's us.
That's America.
There's some about that.
That sounds like America.
Sounds like an eagle flying into the Foxconn factory in China and sweeping up
the iPhone and taking him away.
That sounds kind of like us and the baby in one hand just fucking drops it in
the ocean.
Yeah.
That's sort of a thing that happens.
Talens is big,
long or so that you're not male fish never,
which not mentioning Joe's,
that's cavemen were also living with them at the same time.
If you go to the writing,
you go to the creation
museum.
Have you been,
I know I've been to that area and heard about it,
but right.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
The creation museum is supposed to be so awesome.
They have like these,
these lectures,
they explain how dinosaurs were mentioned in the Bible and how yeah,
and how they were all here together.
Did Noah forget them?
Is that what happened?
They forgot them.
He was on the blowers were late shit to dinosaurs.
Dinosaurs,
that dinosaur people time and
I,
yeah,
I love when people get wacky ideas like that in their head and they just ride
them out to the very end.
I think it's so funny because people think that they're supposed to be able to
feed some people and especially in religion it's sort of,
you know,
think they're supposed to have be able to figure everything out.
Well no I can.
It's easy.
Everything should be easily explained to them and everything.
She'd be like,
no,
the most shit doesn't make sense.
It shouldn't make sense to you.
It doesn't have to make,
so you have a job.
That's the thing that's supposed to make sense to you,
but everything else,
you don't have to know the why things work the way they are.
Unless that's your job.
Well that's science,
handle it.
There's a lot of people working on that shit is also a lot of people that like
an attribute,
like really complex mechanisms to like impossibility.
Like they say,
you're telling me that six 14 whatever it was billion years ago,
something created the universe add a nothing and then from there you can see
with your eyes like,
okay,
I mean man,
where are we?
Begin?
You want to go?
Yes,
that's what I'm telling you.
Next question.
It's like when you're saying,
I could never make a cell phone.
I don't know what's in the cell phone show you do.
You just got to do the work.
Yeah,
but that's what I'm saying.
Like I couldn't,
if,
if somebody brought me all the parts and said put it together and I don't,
I don't need to know how to do it to believe that,
that it's doing the job.
But some people need to act like they need to know how thing works for it to
make sense.
They need,
it needs to make sense to them.
Like,
no,
you didn't study that.
Yeah.
You don't know that what you're telling me a single celled organism can become a
giraffe.
Yes,
I am.
Next question.
Yeah.
It takes millions of years fucker.
Or don't worry about it.
Let the people who were,
who went to college,
and I trust them because they're all liberals,
liberals in the queer lover,
and those liberals brought you your iPhone.
You're not worried about that.
So it just is true.
That's the problem.
It's not a lot of conservative think tanks creating the most innovative new cell
phones.
No,
no,
no.
That's a weird thing.
And they'll,
a comforting thing that I like about a lot of these internet based tech based
businesses,
they seem to be very ethical and moral.
Like they seem to have a connect like Google,
especially Google and a lot of these companies they,
they're,
they're way more open and way more intelligent about their approach to ethics
and morals.
Then a lot of like other corporations.
Yeah.
But I think it's probably like if,
if,
uh,
you know,
I don't know if Walmart is way over here is not ethical,
moral,
moral.
Some people would say that Facebook is here.
They wouldn't say it's like all the way up to the other Facebook.
It's tricky.
Yeah.
Facebook.
I think that like,
you know,
they own,
they own all their information.
They have like they sell it to and they sell it and they make,
you're like,
how does this make money if I'm not paying for it?
How's the weird thing when you go to Google search something and it shows you
like all sorts of other shit that you might be interested in on the right hand
side.
And you're like,
wait a minute,
how the fuck do you know what I like or the new thing where they show like I go,
I looked up a heavy,
like a punching bag.
Like I was thinking of buying a,
I was like,
oh,
maybe we'll buy about punching back.
And now every time I go to websites and being advertised for Everlast bags,
I'm like,
that one time I did a half hour looking at punching bags went,
Nah,
it's dumb.
I'm not going to do that.
Can you just dump your cookies or something like that and that,
uh,
I guess you could,
but it's just that thing that I don't think about until I'm like,
why is it telling me that or,
yeah.
Why is it telling me about like I've made a reservation at a,
this happened this week.
I made a reservation at this hotel I'm staying at now.
My computer's advertising me to stay at the hotel I'm staying at.
I did it.
You already got me.
They already got my money.
No,
I'm not going to,
I'm already staying there.
Well,
it gets even weirder when you have a Google phone because when you have a Google
phone,
it'll tell you like you look something up and I'll show you like how many
minutes that is from your home.
Do you know where I live?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's,
it knows where you go every night.
So it's soon as soon as that's your home,
so it tracks that down and then where you are,
you're 23 minutes from your home.
Fuck.
Do you know where I live?
You should leave for work now.
What are you telling me?
Or the thing that I find with my Google phone,
the technology is still not working the way I will Google something like in La,
like,
oh,
where's that thing?
Just something that's not even,
it's just like,
oh,
where's that thing?
Cause I'm curious if were to,
okay,
there's,
if then I was in San Diego a couple days ago and it was like,
it's four hours to that location.
You googled in Los Angeles.
Like why would I need to know that now I'm not,
I'm not going there.
You're just telling me four hours.
They'd slowly starting to get smart.
It's not quite,
it's not quite there,
but if it does get too smart you,
it's going to be so intrusive or or I have to say convenient.
I mean that's,
I mean you,
you saw the movie her?
No,
uh,
it's a,
it's a good,
I think it's a good,
it's a good flick.
You know what it is.
It's the,
yeah,
it,
we want that,
but maybe not the sex boils.
Actually someone was want the sex part of it,
but we want to be able to walk into our home and go pull up,
my email is put up,
pull up my Netflix queue and Dah,
Dah,
Dah and then,
and then,
and you want to go to work and be like,
send me that that you want.
We want that.
That's what this is all about.
That in a lot of ways.
In some ways you're saying we're getting,
yeah,
people say we're giving up privacy,
but people are like,
people are willing to give up privacy if it comes with a coupon and a f in some
free stuff.
You know what I mean?
Until it bites him in the ass until it bites him in the ass.
And that's the question.
We all have a different place where we were our asses,
we all have different size and shaped acids and I was like,
it's not biting me in the ass shit.
And I'm like,
oh.
But yeah,
the thing with the NSA,
it's like we,
it's hard to say they stay trolled all our data when we're the ones who said
here he would you like our name?
Would you like to data true?
You know,
you download candy crush to your phone and you think I'm just playing a fun game
for free.
And it's like,
no,
it's knows where you are now.
But the real problem is that I let you know that the government was able to read
your emails anytime want these workers
could just like download your Dick Pics.
This is fun to send them off.
And Edward Snowden is telling the truth.
I mean obviously I don't know,
but he said that there's people in his office that were downloading emails from
ex girlfriends and shit and sharing photos and stuff.
I feel like you say like,
people didn't know that.
And I feel like every black barbershop around the country has been talking about
that shit for years.
Black people have always been like the CIA,
you know,
the ca and Vinod crack,
you know what I mean?
Like that level of like we're being watched at all times because every time I
walk into a store there literally is a guy watching me.
You know what I mean?
So I think in the black community,
I don't think the NSA story was as big of a Oh yeah,
the government's watching us.
Yeah.
The black community and the truth or community should get together.
That never seems to work out because the truth of committee goes,
there was no slavery.
Okay.
All right guys.
I had a CIA guy in here,
former CIA,
director of operations,
whatever the fuck.
He was really nice guy.
But I played him,
this Guy Michael Rupert talking about how they were selling drugs and he was a
former La narcotics officer who,
uh,
like literally caught the CIA selling drugs in black communities and was direct.
It was addressing the director of the CIA at the time.
He got fired right after this and I played it for him on the podcast and just
watching them try to
dance around it.
Yeah.
No,
we didn't even,
I mean I let it go after awhile,
but I didn't even get into like Gary Webb or any of the cocaine plane that had
been to Guantanamo Bay twice.
It crashed with tons of cocaine in it.
In Mexico.
Yeah.
Mean there's a lot of evidence that the CIA might've been involved in some form
or someone in the CIA.
I mean,
absolutely.
you know,
yeah.
I mean that's the,
you can't,
you know,
the black people can't flood the ghetto with drugs.
Yeah.
You can't,
you know,
I mean,
every now and again there's a,
Rick freeway were awesome,
but there's not,
that's,
that was the guy that I had on the podcast,
a freeway,
Ricky on it three times.
And one of the Times that I had him on was he discussed how he got into a
connection with this guy who was directly sending the profits to the fucking
contrast.
I mean the,
the whole contras and Sandinistas thing in Nicaragua,
which was the Oliver North scandal that was on television was all at our
freeway.
Ricky selling coke and it's incredible and yet you feel like a little bit,
I feel like at least at least the black guy made some money off of that.
I mean,
yeah,
not certainly he,
I don't know if he would do it all again.
He wouldn't.
He definitely wouldn't.
He's an interesting guy.
He's a,
he's learned a lot from it.
I mean he taught himself how to read in jail once he was arrested for that and
then found a loophole in the argument that got him arrested for three strikes
because it's supposed to be three different charges and he got two kids.
Two different charges was one was one time he was arrested and that doesn't
count as the three strikes law.
So they had to let him out.
He was going to be in jail for the rest of his life.
He figured that out on his own after he learned how to read in jail.
Yeah,
I believe it.
I know.
And it's funny,
I met him at a party one time and it was when I had the show.
And so when I had the show,
I would get like a tension for people who normally wouldn't talk to me.
You know,
like it's,
I met him at a party,
he was very nice,
but he's like,
he's like,
hey man,
give me your number.
And I just had this weird like,
okay,
like,
I don't know,
Mr. Awesome.
I want you to get it to you,
sir.
Did you see a Jim Norton's vice show where he interviewed them?
Oh,
I haven't seen it yet.
Pretty good.
Yeah,
we are very,
very interesting.
He's an interesting guy,
man.
And you know,
he's a real deal.
I mean,
he really did have a multi,
multi,
multimillion dollar cocaine industry and it was really going to the government.
Yes.
I mean,
that's a fact.
Yeah.
No,
and I feel like,
again,
it's a person who sent in a lot of black barbershops in the basement of
churches.
I'm like,
yeah,
you don't get to tell me.
Okay.
I,
I don't think,
I don't believe in a lot of conspiracy theories,
but that to me,
that doesn't feel like a conspiracy theory.
That feels like,
well,
of course.
How else would you get cocaine and crack in the ghetto unless somebody was
greasing the palms to make that happen and that person worked in the government.
That was the government.
Well,
not only that,
if I was sitting around the government and I was sitting around with a bunch of
military industrial complex leaders and everyone's,
you know,
going over how to make money,
you go,
um,
you guys were,
how much coke is getting sold in this country?
Yeah.
It's a lot of code.
We're not going to stop that.
Okay.
They're going to always,
so who's going to make this money?
Do we want the,
the fucking Colombians to make them money or should we just make the money?
Yeah,
we should probably make the money.
Yeah.
We're not going to,
yeah,
I'm not going to stop coke,
but I feel like,
I don't know if they even have the,
we're not going to stop at Congress and he'd be like,
I feel like it's like a new stock thing.
Hey,
coke's making along the way.
Listen to this than that.
I don't feel like it gets to the,
hey,
we can't stop the people from,
you know,
it.
I don't think it's that godfather discussion where like they're animals anyway,
let them destroy themselves and it's like,
oh,
that's making a lot of money.
It's like some lose this.
So it's a,
yeah,
it's apples making money.
We should invest in that.
And cocaine in the ghettos making money.
Yeah.
Actually that the big impediment,
like what's the big problem as law enforcement?
Uh,
that we got that we got that you're going to be fine.
We had,
we already have that.
We already have that in,
well that's from Michael.
Rupert stepped up because he was a former La narcotics officer.
He was a guy who was involved in busting cases and he told his story in no
uncertain terms how he was told to let the case go because it involved the CIA
and he's like,
what are you fucking saying?
Are you telling me that the CIA is selling drugs in the black community?
No.
I'm telling you,
let this case go.
This case that you busted people is actually the CIA.
Are you saying?
Yes.
And that's why you have the police.
That's why the black community has a problem with police in this country.
One reason.
One of,
yeah,
it's hard to,
it's hard to believe that that's the voice of authority.
If you feel like the voice of authority is not honoring its own authority.
You know it's interesting to,
Bay area is also interesting because of a Oakland,
which the the police are notoriously horrible.
Yes.
Like that extra horrible.
Yeah.
Why is that?
I mean because Oakland's crazy cause it's,
cause the Oakland,
Oakland now is becoming gentrified.
So Oakland is not one of the cities that you find in America's top places for
people
to live white paper.
So that's why people,
cause it's becoming gentrified.
So Oakland is really strong,
is really struggling with the fact that it's being gentrified very quickly.
Uh,
but it's just communities that are not even majority black.
Cause as much as people think Oakland's a black city,
it's like 30% black.
It's not,
you know,
people go,
it's funny how few black people,
we have to have people go,
there's a lot of black people in here,
30% more than the national average.
It is more than that,
but it ain't 70% what makes,
what's the national average?
It's like a 11 I think it's like somewhere around 12 or 11 one if you have 11
that's a black neighborhood.
Exactly.
What 11% blind people.
Yeah.
Most neighborhoods are 100% white.
And it's a weird,
and if a black family moves in,
it's like what's happening?
What's going on over there?
What's going on over here?
So let Oakland like a lot of cities that are thought of to be black cities are
over policed and underserved,
you know,
cause people that to me it's like it's just an,
it's a structural institutional racism problem that the,
for example,
and we can talk about it or not talk about it,
but so that if a guy walks down the middle of the street saying like,
like sort of being a teenager who's allowed guy walking down the street,
a white teenager might get told,
get the fuck out of the street and the guy who,
I'm not getting a street dude grab and put them on the corner,
don't do this shit again.
But a black teenager who walks down the middle,
the street and goes,
I'm not getting on the street ends up debt,
is my opinion on that situation that we get that even with that things that
would be,
that would be sort of like if you're white,
they would be like,
all right,
let's see.
We're not going to make a big deal out of this,
that when you're black,
it can end up in your death because of the approach to policing black people in
this country.
Do you think that that's a problem inherent with police officers or is it
because they're dealing with so much violence,
it's coming from black people?
Is it because there have been told to handle cases differently?
I think it's a,
I think it's,
the America was founded on racism,
so I think it's a,
it's a,
I'm not going to necessarily say cops are the problem cops,
the way people were black people are policing is a symptom of the fact that
American,
the cornerstone of America is racism and everything we built was on that.
And that's why people want to have,
when you won't have the reparations discussion,
it's like,
well,
you know how we get a lot of cheap labor in this country,
but you know,
how do we get to be the richest country in the world for a while?
Because we had a 40 year headstart on the labor.
You know what I mean?
Like we weren't paying,
they weren't,
people weren't being paid to build this country.
So,
uh,
I think that when the cornerstone of this country is founded on racism and the
people who police the country are trying to protect the country's reputation and
name that means a lot of times they,
they use racism.
Racism is a part of how they police the country.
How,
can you ever fix a scenario where the entire culture was established with slave
labor?
If a giant percentage of what made America what it is,
was established because of slave labor,
how does that get fixed?
Like how does that ever balance it out?
How does it,
it does it just come naturally over a course of a long period of time?
Definitely doesn't come think socially engineered.
It's,
it has to be a,
yeah.
Uh,
it has,
something has to jumpstart the process.
I think that the,
the,
you can't say affirmative action in this country without some people go over to
[inaudible] then a white man won't have a job.
And it's like,
but actually it's like you have to jumpstart the process.
You have to and maybe it's for me it's like if I literally said that I said this
really if every black man in this country was given therapy,
cause I feel like being black in America you have a mild form of PTSD or severe
form of Ptsd depending upon where you live and if you made it and you guarantee
that the schools in the inner city we're good that they were well funded public
schools where you could get where you could pay.
You may not get a good education here but this is a place where good education
happens easily.
And that's not true of most schools in the inner city.
And if you said,
and if you made it friendly for major grocery stores to be in the inner city so
that you know you've been in a poor neighborhood,
like that's the grocery store,
you know where it's not a major chain grocery store,
it's a 99 cent store that also has fruit.
You know what I mean?
It's like that you,
you said that if you made it so that it was friendly for those companies coming
to move there.
Cause a lot of the gentrification happens.
It's like people know their neighborhoods are being gentrified.
When the nine 9 cent close door closes down in a whole foods opens,
they're like,
oh finally we have,
we can't afford to shop there.
You know,
so you have to change the structures of the neighborhoods.
You have to change the structures of how people are being,
how people are living their lives and there's no,
there's no motivation to do that.
No,
I think that the only,
the,
the only hope that we have of that is that,
you know,
there's professional sports.
I look at that,
like the money that is being made in professional sports like there at some of
these guys are,
a lot of these guys are going to go broke,
but in a,
in a hundred years we'll be dealing with the Jordan Foundation.
The way we're dealing with the Rockefellers,
you know what I'm saying?
Magic Johnson did a bad job.
Then at some point,
I hope that some of these people who have this like fuck you money can actually
figure out a way to port back in,
but they can't necessarily like charter schools.
Like Jalen rose has a charter school specifically in Detroit to go,
I need to help jumpstart this situation myself.
But it's hard to rely on individuals to do that.
And the,
until America goes,
it's in our best interest to make poor neighborhoods better and easier.
And I'm not just on my black,
I just in general,
poor neighborhoods better.
It will make a better country until the government feels like that's an
important thing.
And also,
you know,
we have this one president that Brock is pretty good and pretty liberal,
but we don't know what the next one's going to look like.
And then the next one's going to look like until the country sort of as a whole
goes,
you know,
that we get to that tipping point where we need to,
we should,
all the schools should be good.
You know,
uh,
health care,
it shouldn't bankrupt,
you know,
you know you shouldn't,
you shouldn't get,
you shouldn't have a car accident.
It's amazing that we have to even say these things.
It seems like it should be like the staples of a,
a culture.
Yeah.
That you know,
in the UK they go,
what do you mean you went broke because you had,
because you've got a broken leg or something.
You know why I always think of in terms of what is the number one resource that
we have in America,
it's not natural resources.
It's human beings.
And wouldn't American be stronger if there were less people that were losers?
So what's the best way to make less people losers work with children?
I feel like,
I think they should have community centers and in any poor neighborhoods have a
place where kids can escape.
That's really well staffed with people that are excellent counselors,
people that are teaching sports and martial arts and places where kids can work
on theirs.
They're studying.
They could have computers to use to access for books and all kinds of other shit
so that they can have a place that they can get in away from the crime and just
that alone will stop a lot of fucking crime.
And it'll give kids a place where they can,
they have a home away from home,
they have something.
So if their parents work during the day and they don't,
they don't want to go home and just stare at the walls.
They have somewhere to go to.
They have people that they can look up to that can help them.
Counselors and you're,
you're giving people more of a chance to be a successful human when you do that.
You're strengthening the country.
Yeah,
that's,
and I don't think people see it that way.
They see somehow like it's again to hand out their animals,
their animals yourself up by your bootstraps,
which to me is like crazy.
It's crazy.
And I think that people don't see,
it's so stupid.
It's like if you have an infection in your finger and you let it go,
it's going to kill you.
You know what I mean?
Like you have to sort of go,
we need to address this and theirs and we can either address it now or we can
wait until like,
you know,
do we have to burn down Ferguson,
Missouri to get more cops to patrol?
Yeah.
We might give up my place in Connecticut.
We need to get that cut.
Our cops need tanks.
Arts cops definitely need tanks cause those blasts.
The Massey Ferguson.
Yeah.
Sentence drones that people don't take it.
They don't take it seriously.
And I think that that's the,
until you people go,
Oh,
if we've,
if stronger communities lead to a stronger America,
there should be thinking,
like you said,
there should be things that are just taken for granted and you know how they're
going to do that.
Oh,
taxes from marijuana.
Yes,
exactly.
That's how,
that's my solution.
Ladies and gentleman legalized marijuana.
39% tax.
Like Colorado is doing hundreds of millions of dollars at your disposal.
And I've heard the thing about the,
I don't know if they figured it out,
but like,
because you're,
you,
you can't because the federal government hasn't legalize marijuana.
There's all this money that the pot dispensaries are making.
They're slowly starting to care.
Put it at the bank.
Exactly.
Just like,
oh,
come on America.
Yeah,
well it's the federal government trying to fuck with people and that's what it
is.
And not only that,
they're arresting people that are using these,
these federal parks,
like they're smoking weed in states where it's legal,
but they go to the park and they s they spark up a joint in a state park and
then the federal government comes in and the rest of them,
even though Barack Obama I think has been pretty clear about,
they're not trying to prosecute the president of the United States is,
is we're not trying to go after these things.
Well,
he has been pretty clear about that.
However,
his administration and the DEA has prosecuted a lot of fucking people in states
where medical marijuana is legal.
The other thing they do,
which is really cute,
is they arrest people.
They take all their weed,
they take all their money and then they say the case is pending and they just
have to sit there and they don't do anything about it.
But they stole $500,000 from them in $1 million worth of weed.
And then just sit in there waiting to find out whether or not you're going to go
to jail.
And some of them
do.
I have a friend who's gone to jail because of it.
I know several people that have gone to jail during the Obama Administration for
selling medical marijuana that's legal.
So he's kind of full of shit when it comes to that.
He's,
I mean he,
you know,
I,
I like,
I like Brock.
I'm not in love with him anymore,
but it happened.
Did you guys break up?
We broke.
What caused it?
For me,
the thing that actually caused it over and over again was every time there was
like,
um,
like Troy Davis,
the guy who was on death row in Texas,
who people were like,
the evidence says that he didn't do it.
And there are people,
like I remember on Twitter people like say something,
Brock say something.
Just if people were like,
well it's not his jurisdiction.
Every time there's an issue that is that fall squarely on the head of black
people in this country and Barack sort of tippy toes around her,
it doesn't address it head on soon enough.
I feel like he,
that's why we elected a black president.
That's why black people went out to vote.
It's because we wanted somebody who had our back and every time he doesn't and
he can't,
he can't fix problems.
I don't expect them to fix things.
But when it takes them four days to talk about Ferguson and as he says,
he didn't want to say anything too quickly or do you want to say,
cause he didn't want to be seen as putting his thumb on the scale of justice.
I'm like,
Oh dude,
that's why I elected you.
I wanted your thumb on the scale of justice.
And that's because that's what we,
it's again,
we need to jumpstart the system.
And so for me,
the stuff like that with uh,
you know,
with the sort of the,
and again,
yes,
if he talks about Trayvon Martin,
people go even,
even,
but I'm going,
yeah,
well that's the job.
The job is to get yelled at.
Sometimes the job is to take a hat is to have a hard week because you take a
good stance.
If you take a stance anyway,
you're going to get yelled at.
Yeah.
So I don't pro or con,
if he took an Andrew Zimmerman stance that George would have the fuck his name
is,
or he took a Trayvon Martin stance,
w whoevers side,
he cited on,
you're going to face an assault of opinion.
But my contention is that black people rallied around a black president because
they're like,
we meet,
you know,
born again.
Christians had a voice in the,
in the White House with George W.
Bush and George Bush did not hide his boarding and Christian this,
he didn't,
he said,
God all the time.
He said,
where it God's because you know that stuff.
Whereas Brock,
he know he,
he,
he's clearly walking a fine line,
which I get it.
I wouldn't want to trade places with them.
I wouldn't want to be the first black,
that fifth black president,
any president or any president,
white president.
You did take the job.
You did go get it.
You didn't,
you didn't get assigned the job.
Don't you think that that job's unimaginably difficult and unmanageable?
He difficult.
It is,
but you took the job.
I'm not,
you know,
it's,
yeah,
it is,
but just uh,
you know,
everything is,
we all have our things we pick and it's hard to do.
It's hard to be a standup comedian,
but you,
we took the job,
you know,
not saying it's,
I'm not comparing it to being a president,
a stand up comedian.
You can actually do it.
You can't,
you're getting the,
the White House.
You can't actually be the president,
you know,
I cannot really,
the presidents get in there,
man.
You are faced with just a fucking tidal wave of special interest groups and
money and pull and push.
Probably.
It's probably similar to having your own late night talk show.
They go,
this is how it's done.
You're going to do a cold opening.
But I don't want to do a cold opening,
except you never get to that Jon Stewart position where you'd tell everybody to
fuck off.
No,
because you don't get to be president for 20 years too,
but you'll be in the show is not the country.
Yeah.
No,
it's not the country,
dude.
We're out of time.
We did.
We just did three hours.
I knew I was coming in here for the long haul,
but through and through I was a trying to keep the ball.
That was fun.
What are you doing next?
Is there any,
if you have any projects in the world could look forward to?
Yeah,
I do have a big project in the world.
First of all,
I'm taking a month off because my wife's going to have our second kid.
Uh,
but people can't look forward to that.
But then in November,
I'm going out him like my most extensive tour ever.
Oh,
cool.
Beautiful.
It's called the owe everything to her.
Everything.
Oh,
everything.
What's wrong.
Oh,
everything.
So I will be hitting a mini markets.
I would like that I've never hit before.
And then places I love to go to.
So beautiful.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
your website,
[inaudible] Dot Com k and may you be e l l.com or Twitter and Facebook.
I'm a w Kamau bell at w Kamau Bell.
If you look up w Kamau Bell,
I'm the one at this point to do an internet shop.
Man.
Just tell you're showing the internet.
You know,
it's,
it's getting out of New York and like sort of the Hayes has been lifted and the
storm has passed over.
And I feel like I've had like,
I've just gotten back into standup again.
I'm like,
oh,
it's the guy I remember that I was okay.
Yeah,
but I'm a little bit wiser.
I liked this guy,
so it's coming something.
I'm working on some stuff.
Beautiful.
Listen,
man,
there's been a lot of fun.
Thank you very much.
I really appreciate the conversation.
It's been an honor,
man.
Thanks.
Thank you,
sir.
All right,
come on.
Bella is gentlemen,
see soon.
Big Kiss.